want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level talent at something so today let's
live your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from simon sinek
enjoy
define for us an infinite game
so in the mid 1980s a theologian named
james carsey wrote this little book
called finite infinite games in which he
defines these two kinds of games finite
games which have known players fixed
rules and agreed upon objectives
football right there's always a
beginning a middle and an end
and the
objective is to win the game
um and then there's infinite games
infinite games are defined as known and
unknown players you don't necessarily
know who all the other players are
the rules are changeable you can play
however you want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible
what i find so fascinating about this
idea when i first learned about it is we
are players in multiple infinite games
every day of our lives there's just no
such thing as being the winner in your
marriage you know
um
there's no such thing as winning global
politics and there's definitely no such
thing as winning business
is an infinite game
um and yet when we listen to the
language of too many leaders they talk
about being number one being the best
and beating their competition
based on what there's no agreed upon
objectives there's no agreed upon time
frames and so what ends up happening is
you have people building organizations
and leading with a finite mindset
playing to win in a game where there's
no such thing as winning
and when we play with a finite mindset
in an infinite game there's a few very
predictable and consistent outcomes
amongst which include the decline of
trust
the decline of cooperation
uh the decline of innovation all of
which contribute to the eventual demise
of the organization itself um and so
what i wrote about is is is what it
means to lead with an infinite mindset
because we teach leadership as if it
were a finite game um
you know people start business with the
goal of winning or being number one
and that's a problem um because that's
impossible um so what i wrote about in
the infinite game is is leading with an
infinite mindset i recognize that
business is an infinite game and almost
all of the leadership in business today
is finite minded and so there's
literally you can't show up to a game of
basketball ready to play football like
it's not going to go well we overuse
sports analogies in business
but sports has beginning middle and end
there actually is a finish line right we
overuse the analogies they're incorrect
analogies you know running a business is
the same as as getting healthy it's a
lifestyle leadership is a lifestyle an
infinite mindset is a lifestyle right so
for example you can't get healthy by
going to the gym for nine hours it
doesn't work right um
but if you go every single day for 20
minutes
you'll absolutely get into shape 100
but i don't know when and it's different
times for different people right and
leading is the same thing you can
absolutely have fitness goals you can
absolutely have finite goals within the
infinite context of being healthy but
there's a practice that you have to do
you have to get enough sleep you have to
go to the gym you have to eat well you
have to protect your relationships you
know because healthy relationships
really matter to our health and you have
to do all those things vigilantly and if
you miss your health goal it's okay you
keep working at it and you know you will
hit it business is the same who says
that you have to meet this goal on this
arbitrary date now it helps to drive and
it's good to have incentives and we
we're we're very goal-oriented species
that's fine but if we miss the thing
it's fine we just keep working towards
it like they're guidance they're not
absolutes because they're arbitrary
dates and arbitrary numbers and even if
you do hit your fitness goal you don't
get to stop working out
you have to keep going for the rest of
your life
right and this is what leading with an
infinite mindset means
here's an example this is a normal
scenario in business right we will give
a team um a target a goal to hit by a
certain time frame usually a year um
because that's usually when we pay taxes
right
that's the only reason things are done
in years right if we pay taxes every 18
months all the goals would be 18 months
right
so we usually give people a financial
target and there's two teams one that is
driven solely by hitting that goal
because all they care about is getting
their bonus at the end of that goal
morale is up and down if they happen to
have a good month morale is up if they
have a bad month morale is down
retention is terrible they can't hold on
to employees
nobody really trusts each other the boss
is toxic and right before the end of the
financial year they
have some mad push where they're
dropping prices all over the place and
they're managed to drive revenues and
hit the goal right the problem is we
bonus that team we bonus that leader
because of what uh because of the goal
they hit right and basically what we're
doing is spreading a message to the rest
of the company saying we don't care how
you get there we don't care if you step
on your people we don't care if you act
unethically if you hit your number
you're going to do very well in this
company versus another team that's doing
extremely well it's good steady slow
growth like really
really on target you know
not the highs and lows the peaks and
valleys morale is super high retention
is amazing it's a model team they trust
each other they share information and
they miss their goal on the agreed upon
date right at the end of the year
they're just shy of it but clearly you
can see from the trend data they're
going to hit it at 13 or 14 months the
problem is we don't give that person
anything we don't give that team
anything
right and this is part of the problem
when you have an infinite mindset
absolutely have the goals but the trend
matters more how you get there matters
as much if not more and we pay attention
to that so even if i hit my fitness goal
i'm eating better i'm sleeping better my
relationships are great i'm going to the
gym yes i miss my goal
but i know
if i just keep going i'll hit it i'm
getting healthier and healthier right i
just got the timing wrong and this is
what we need to build into business that
infinite mindset yes have the goals yes
have the ambitions yes have the annual
targets if we miss them as long as we're
doing the right things we have the right
lifestyle to take us there that's a much
healthier way to live a life and a much
healthier way to build an organization
what i'm saying is that the business
needs to operate in a way in which in
which uh
they care about their people more
and uh
and
and then these arbitrary finite things
aren't the end all be all right and
create an environment which we can have
stressful moments but there's not the
sustained stress with the steady type of
coordinates every day every day of our
lives which we know has contributed to
increases in cancer diabetes and heart
disease i mean our jobs are literally
killing us yeah
so i think short bursts of stress are
not the problem the life that i live is
actually i think pretty healthy yeah
it's this it's this steady drip of
cortisol when you go to a job where you
you know where we don't believe that our
bosses care about us and the company
doesn't care about us and they have
annual rounds of layoffs to balance the
books every year
they don't they see me as a number and
then then the company has the audacity
to say you know millennials aren't loyal
it's not what are you kidding me it's
like they've entered into a workforce in
which they're just treated as a
disposable commodity why should they
give you loyalty show a little loyalty
to your people and you'll be amazed the
loyalty they'll give back right so i
think that's a much unhealthier
environment and that's what i rail
against we're social animals um our
happiness our joy our success everything
is dependent on our relationships um and
we respond to the environments we're in
you can take a good person and put them
about it in a bad environment and
they're capable of doing bad things
likewise you can take a person that the
group or even society has given up on
and you put them in a good environment
and they're capable of turning their
lives around and really making something
remarkable out of themselves
we are social animals and we respond to
the environments we're in and leaders
are responsible for building that
environment
and if you create an environment in
which people feel safe amongst their own
we will naturally the natural human
response to those conditions is trust
and cooperation
remember trust and cooperation are
feelings they're not instructions
there's no power point or pitch that you
can give upon the end that someone will
trust you you can't tell somebody trust
me it doesn't work that way they're
feelings
um likewise if you create an environment
where we actually fear each other fear
the people with whom we work the natural
human reaction to that
that environment is paranoia cynicism
mistrust and self-interest that's what
happens there's enough danger outside
the organization there's enough stuff
going on outside that we should have to
fear the people we work with or fear our
own leaders
and most leaders don't get this most
leaders think leadership is about being
in charge
no it's not it's about taking care of
those in your charge
most leaders think everybody works for
them
nope you work for the people in your
organization it is your responsibility
to take care of them make them feel safe
and they will naturally want to
cooperate and work hard and give you
their blood and sweat and tears to
advance your vision all they ask is you
take care of them make them feel valued
and valuable and the rest takes care of
itself it's like a parent it's like a
coach teach them train them give them
the opportunity to fall and try again
and and if they fear the leader then
they're gonna take steps to protect
themselves
from the leader
it's pervasive in our world today if you
work in an organization where where it's
standard practice for employees to feel
the need to send a cya email after every
single decision they make
that is a sign that they are taking time
and energy out of their day away from
doing their job in order to protect
themselves from their own leaders
that's what that is
you know anybody who keeps a file of all
the good things they've done in their
career just in case they need it
that is people taking time and energy
away from doing their jobs in order to
protect themselves from their own
organization
so you can't ask those people to give
you the best of their thinking and be
more productive if you've created an
environment where they're forced to
protect themselves from you you know
and this is what i learned and so it's
all about this environment the circle of
safety we come to work feeling
uncomfortable that some of the decisions
that are being made
don't benefit the good of the employee
um that it really benefits this this
artificial constituency that we call the
shareholder which is really just a bunch
of institutional investors there's this
shareholder myth because there's been a
steady decline of the middle class being
involved in the stock market for years
and the whole point of the stock market
was that we all get to share in the
wealth that we helped build because it's
on the back of average joe employees
that produced the great wealth in the
nation and the whole point of the stock
market the genius of the modern day
corporation the genius of the public
company was that we all get to share in
the wealth that we're helping produce
unfortunately over the course of the 80s
and 90s we've seen systems produced
where we're seeing the general
population the middle class actually be
less included in that success
and the reason i wrote the infinite game
was because i myself
got tired of being told by people in
positions of authority or people of
extreme wealth that i was naive that i
don't understand how business business
works and for many years i believed them
i thought maybe i am the dumb one right
we all kind of feel that because they
have the power they have the authority
they have the money they know more than
we do
but we still go to work and feel
uncomfortable and it turns out that that
discomfort that gut feeling that says
that there's something wrong here turns
out that the majority actually knows
something
uh and to me this is a world is flat
moment that that the the the people
who've learned to game the system
that this discomfort that we feel we're
we actually are right like they actually
don't understand the game they're in
business is an infinite game and when
you play with a finite mindset lots of
people suffer including the companies
that they themselves are trying to build
that's the great irony the great irony
is the way you build great companies
is with an infinite mindset the way you
build great companies is by prioritizing
people before profit the way you build
great companies is will before resources
um both both things important but there
has to be this general leaning where we
can feel
when we come to work and feel
like we're part of something bigger than
ourselves where we feel that our work
and our effort is worth more than simply
the money we make i'm a lover of
creative people
um and so
any sort of expression of of of how you
see the world in with different
terminology is fascinating to me and so
even though i myself i'm a photographer
um so i have that visual aspect i'm a
huge fan of modern dance and spend a lot
of time
sort of with dancers and in the dance
world and have you know
tried my hand at choreography just to
see you know
i'm not good but i i like the idea of
trying it you know um and uh and so for
me it's about perspective which is when
i when when you hang out with dancers
and you you know you sort of learn to
dance a little bit or you learn to
choreograph a little bit or you learn to
paint a little bit you know i'm not a
painter but i painted a painting
recently you know um
you know if you if you unders it's like
chaos theory you know everything's
connected right you know it's like we we
conveniently divide up our lives like
here's my personal life here's my
professional life i'm you know here's my
social life i'm looking to find balance
it's just you you know and all the same
things apply and so if you're if you're
good here you can apply what you learn
here to there you know and so when you
when you learn how things interconnect
and and people interconnect and how
human relationships work and presence i
mean you want to learn about presence
take a dance class you learn all about
how to present yourself and be forwards
you know take an acting class learn how
to you know present your speech people
say simon how'd you learn this is like
i'm exposed to all of this
so the tools i've learned have just
mainly been different perspectives on
how other people use their creative
talents to see the world and if i can
get little pieces of those
they they help me in many many different
ways imagine we're standing
in a big empty room right
and we're standing in one corner and i
give you a simple instruction
i want you to go to that corner in a
straight line
right off you go no big deal right
without telling you i slip a chair in
front of you what do you do
you go around the chair
now you just disobeyed what i told you
to do i told you to go to that corner
straight line
but this is the amazing things about
human beings which is when we're given a
clear destination
we use our own creativity and our own
sense of innovation and our own
problem-solving abilities to overcome
obstacles to get to the destination in
other words the destination is more
important than the route
right we are flexible about the route we
are obsessed with the destination reset
we're standing in the corner together
and i give you a simple instruction
go somewhere in this room in a straight
line
and you say to me where do you want me
to go i'm like i don't know you're smart
figure it out go in a straight line and
so you pick a point and you start
walking and without telling you i put a
chair in front of you and what do you do
you come to a grinding halt and i say
what did you stop for you go will you
put a chair in front of me
or you'll make a sudden turn and go in
another direction
right and this is the problem it's the
same obstacle
the difference is when you have a clear
set at a clear destination the obstacles
become easy to overcome when you don't
have a clear destination you keep coming
to a grinding halt and what we do in our
companies is we're counting the steps
we're taking along the route but we're
never looking at the destination right
so company says
made a million dollars this year we were
only planning on making eight hundred
thousand like we took ten steps we're
only planning on taking eight
where are you going no clue right
we count the steps and so the point is
is that people want to feel that the
effort that they're exerting actually
are moving somewhere and so successful
measurement successful recognition is
not just for the steps you take it's not
just for the effort it's that the effort
you exerted moved us closer to where
we're trying to get to and that get to
should be some crazy ideal my ideal is
to live in a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning you know inspired to go to work
and fulfilled by the work that they do
and the the couple of measurements that
i use are if the book is selling and i
by the way people ask me how many have
you sold i have no clue i've never asked
the publisher because i don't care i
really don't care how many i've sold
what i care about is the amazon rankings
and that those are going steady or up
and not plummeting because that means
other people right because i don't have
a publicist i don't have a marketing
strategy on purpose i didn't hire one of
those companies to sell the book for me
and the reason is is because i'm not
interested in book sales i'm interested
in spreading an idea and so i just use
that as a metric to help me understand
am i sort of marching in the because the
more i preach is it resonating
you know and so you have a couple of
these imperfect measurements that help
you understand are you going along the
way so it's not just great effort look
what you achieved because that's what
we're doing now
right our goal is to increase top line
revenues by 50 million dollars
for what reason
right which is we have to know the
destination and then
we say
amazing you took us that much closer and
if we go to the right it's because we
were overcoming an obstacle
if we hadn't gone to the right we would
have been stuck forever thank you
you know it's not always straight lines
it's not always straight lines
but it's it's in one direction she's
pulling the cane out rarely are we
instant experts you may have a
particular gift
or um affinity towards something but you
still get better um
you know
people would pay me high compliments
when i started speaking and then people
who've seen me a year or two later say
that i'm even better and i feel it why
is that
because you you you learn more you know
i i think that hubris is dangerous i
think to think that you're an expert in
anything is a foolish
pursuit um you're never you're never as
good as you could be there's always room
for improvement there's always room to
get better um you don't that doesn't
mean you have to listen to all the
advice um just you know not necessarily
does everybody know best but but to
believe that you can be better and to
believe that you can offer more
is is a constant pursuit
you know i used to think being a public
speaker meant being poised and
presenting in a way that was compelling
and speaking at the right pace and
that's that's a part of it
um but but i um have been taking more
risks lately doing things that are
very unstructured and very uncomfortable
and i will now do like if i have an hour
to speak i'd rather speak for 20 minutes
and do 40 minutes worth of questions and
who knows how that's gonna go and that
to me is the best and so i'm a better
speaker because now i'm way more open to
the unknown where a few years ago that
that would have scared me
leadership is not about being in charge
it's about taking care of those in our
charge and the very responsibility of a
leader
is not to drive performance
leaders are not responsible for the
results leaders are responsible for the
people who are responsible for the
results
and the problem is we don't teach people
how to lead
right when you're very very junior we
give people tons of training how to do
their jobs some people get advanced
degrees how to do their jobs so that
they'll be good at them and if you're
really good at your job will promote you
and eventually you get promoted to a
position where you're now responsible
for the people who do the job you used
to do and we don't teach you how to do
that so how can we expect people to be
good at their jobs if we don't train
them how to do it like would you go see
a doctor that didn't go to medical
school no so why would we work for a
leader who has no training in being a
leader
that's why we get managers that's why we
get micromanagers that's why we get
toxicity it's not because they're bad
people it's because they don't know what
they're doing
and they're making it up as they go
along and those lucky times that we get
to work for a great leader well they
were lucky that they probably had a
great leader before them or they learned
it somewhere else or maybe they had a
terrible leader and they committed to do
the total opposite of everything the
point is they learned it well we have to
teach leadership so that leaders can
create environments in which all of us
can work to our natural best that
produces trusting teams the great irony
of all of this which is the power
belongs to the people this is a this is
just an anthropological truth sure you
know the power always belongs to the
people which is why dictators bus in
crowds to
to give the appearance that they're
popular or they actually have fake
elections to give the appearance that
they have a mandate
dictators do that right if if
the people didn't have the power
dictators wouldn't need rallies and they
wouldn't need elections right right
dictators fear the people
right
because people have the power in any op
in any population in any organization
and what keeps
dictators and bad leaders authorities in
power is by keeping the people divided
because if you can create mistrust
amongst neighbors
then the people can never come together
and never just depose the leader and so
if you look at any dictatorship that
ever existed there are systems look at
east germany during the cold war you
know we didn't know who was telling on
us so everybody kept to themselves and
nobody trusted anybody neighbors didn't
trust neighbors and that allows
authoritarian organizations to
to do as they please
the people which when people come
together
you know it's it's not it's not
it's not congress that just woke up one
day and decided the civil rights act
that's a pretty good idea it was
thousands and thousands and thousands of
people marching
you know in in in peaceful protest
um that put unbelievable pressure
and anything that's ever happened in the
world where there's been revolutionary
evolution happen this way yeah people
always have the power and this is very
true in the business as well the people
have the power and so if we have mass
layoffs on an annualized basis and you
create internal competition what you're
doing is you're pitting people against
people especially if you create a system
where we're only incentivized based on
individual performance so in a sales
organization for example if my income
literally depends on how many sales i
get and you're gonna
i'm gonna keep stuff away why would i
help you yeah right
keep the people divided you keep the
system that we've got but as soon as the
people come together
good things happen we are the sum total
of how we were raised and the
experiences we had we when we were kids
good or bad and what i find remarkable
when i've done these and i've asked
people tell me a specific early happy
childhood memory and sometimes
somebody will stare at me and very
uncomfortably say i did not have a happy
childhood i don't have any happy
memories
um and i'll say well tell me a sad one
then
and i'll and so here's one of the actual
things that somebody told me
they had a very a very abusive father
and one of the things they remember is
her and her brother her baby brother
hiding from their father when he went on
a on a rampage and she remembers holding
her brother and covering him up while
they hid in the closet and she tells
this
traumatic difficult sad story
and it occurred to me while i was
listening to the story i said you told
me about how you made a specific attempt
to cover your brother to protect your
brother that's positive in other words
what you'll find is even in difficulty
you will find these these these
strengths that come out and that's who
this person was this person at her core
was a protector that she would stand in
the way of those uh
who who might be harmed in other words
it was very very positive
i'm a great believer in the world of
balance that
there's a cost for everything that is
good that happens to us where everything
we gain comes at a cost but everything
bad
also offers some silver lining there's
always a positive in something bad that
happens as well so the the one of the
dirty secrets about finding your why is
you actually don't have to have happy
childhood memories you just have to have
childhood memories
and there are still patterns in there
that reveal who you actually are and so
some of those coping mechanisms
though in their specific form i would
venture to say that there's still some
things that came out of that that help
make you who you are that offer you
great value so
i am uncomfortable with this concept of
work-life balance
um
because balance is achieved with two
opposing forces and why should work and
life be in opposition right and
uh i i don't think there's if you don't
have work-life balance if you're
struggling to find work-life balance no
amount of yoga will fix that right
um taking off an extra week of vacation
and by the way vacation means you're not
working on the beach that's just
telecommuting from a beach um
but i believe in in
uh that the
that you're able to build a life
where
work and
personal life become
not only say interchangeable but smooth
and what i mean by that is they're not
necessarily confined by hours in a day
but rather where i choose to give effort
so for example if it's four o'clock in
the afternoon technically part of the
workday and you're hankering for a run
because it's a day like this
you go for a run
like
that's you know and one of the things
one of the mistakes that i've made
was treating
things that are important to my mind my
body my spirit
as stump something that i'm supposed
only supposed to do off hours or on
weekends
but just like i can't decide when i have
an idea sometimes it's on saturday and
sometimes it's in the evening
i also can't decide when i need a break
sometimes it's something i feel that's
something i plan for and so
we've gotten really good it's imperfect
you know sometimes responsibility takes
precedence but we've gotten really good
in our little company that if somebody
wants to take
an afternoon to be with their kids they
put in their calendar with my kids
a long time ago i used to have when i
when i had um a different form of
business before all of this stuff we
used to have things called duvet days
which i i
remember we had like five duvet days a
year or something and a duvet day was
you wake up in the morning
you just don't want to come to work
you're totally healthy
or it's a beautiful day and i just would
rather go to the beach so you'd call up
and leave a message at eight o'clock in
the morning or seven o'clock and then
we'll be like hey i'm taking a duvet day
i'll see you tomorrow and no one would
bother you right and people like that's
amazing that you do that sign i'm like
people are doing that anyway it's called
i think i have a 24-hour bug i'm going
to be at work today and they go to the
beach
so just call it out
um
you know
schedule
time at the gym in the middle of the day
if that's when you like working out and
i just found the the more seamless that
we can make work in life
um the more we start to enjoy both more
because they're not they're not opposing
it's akin to how do we be more authentic
you know
um and and the way so many companies
tackle that is they go and do market
research
right we go and do focus groups uh to
find out how we can differentiate
ourselves
um which i think is funny which is the
which is the same thing as asking your
friends sort of
how should i talk to you and how should
i dress so that you'll like me more
and your friends are going to look and
be like what you're like how do you want
me to talk to you and how do you want me
to dress so that you'll like me more
because i care
and your friends will be like i don't
know just be yourself right and this is
what companies do they go get outside
advice
to how to be themselves how they should
how they should present themselves to
the outside world
the way you differentiate yourself is
you is you are yourself it sounds silly
but it's true which is you know what
your vision is and your causes you know
what you stand for you know what your
your your culture is which means you
know what your values are just like a
person
right and you work hard imperfectly
because like a person we're imperfect
and messy and you work hard
to do things that represent what you
stand for and operate in a way that
represent your values
and what starts to happen is you start
to stand out
because you're consistent
and people start to be able to say i
know what you stand for and you start to
become predictable and you're either
very attractive to some people who
believe what you believe or you
people don't like you because they don't
believe what you believe both of those
things are good and then there's always
people in the middle who just want to do
business with you because the
transaction is good and the the you know
the price happens to be right the
product happens to meet a certain spec
certain specs i'll do business with you
but it's it's the ones who believe what
you believe it's the loyal ones that
make it that make a company stand out
um and do more to spread the good word
of your organization than you could ever
do with advertising and so it the irony
is is
live true to your values
make decisions consistent with what you
stand for which is seen by employees as
well as customers by the way
people who believe what you believe want
to work there and want to be loyal to
the company because working here says
something about who i am
um you know if i say i work for apple
you actually know something about me
even though you know nothing about me
just because apple is good
and by the way there's no difference
between a customer and an employee it's
just a behavioral difference they either
work for you or or i buy from you but
ultimately
i believe what you believe the behavior
may be different
um so i think that the best thing a
company can do to stand out
is is to is to stand for something and
live by its own values here's what i've
learned about mentorship
mentorship is not something you ask
somebody to do like will you be my
friend it doesn't work like that um when
you find somebody you get along with you
share values you share beliefs you spend
time with them you get to know them you
develop trust you take
you're vulnerable with them you open up
to them and you discover that you become
friends it's what happens you start off
as simply acquaintances um in my
experience mentorship is exactly the
same um there were people who were much
more experienced than me who had wisdom
that i didn't have and i when i would
call them they would take my calls and
when when i would ask them questions
they would always take the time to give
me answers
and over the course of time they became
my mentors like they became my friends
and i remember one time i was with one
of my mentors ron bruder an amazing guy
and i was leaving his house and i put my
arm around him i said you know i'm glad
you're my mentor and he looked at me and
he said i'm glad you're mine and it
caught me completely off guard and true
mentorship like true friendship is not a
one-way street it's not about one person
only giving advice to the other both
people are showing up to give and both
people are showing up uh to learn um but
you can't ask someone to be your mentor
especially someone who's a total
stranger knock on their door and say
will you be my mentor if they don't know
you and you've never met them it's like
friendship you cultivate a relationship
and if that person is always there for
you and wants to see you thrive and
succeed and believes in you
then perhaps they will become your
mentor like making a friend discovering
your why is just the beginning
in order to enjoy all the benefits of
having a clearly articulated why you'll
need to have the courage and discipline
to use it
like thomas edison said vision with that
execution is hallucination
there is an ideal order for implementing
your why though sometimes reality does
get in the way and it all starts with
you our natural tendency is to start
with the tangible we define our value by
what we do so it takes practice to start
with why like riding a bicycle at first
we're unsure unsteady we're in our heads
thinking about all the things we need to
do pedal fast keep enough speed so we
don't fall over
we have to really concentrate we may
even fall over even scrape our knees but
we get back on the bike and try again
and eventually it becomes natural
starting with why is no different at
first it feels awkward it may not even
work but with practice it will become so
natural that you won't even be able to
imagine a time when you couldn't do it
just like riding a bicycle
in time your why will act as a filter
for many of the decisions and choices
you make it becomes a tool to help you
find a job or seize an opportunity in
which you're more likely to succeed
it removes a lot of the guessing here's
a metaphor to show you what i mean it's
called the celery test
we're constantly asking people for their
advice on what to do or how to do it
it's like going to a dinner party and
somebody says do you know what you need
you need m ms we've done so well with m
m's you've got to use m ms somebody else
says to us rice milk in this economy you
have to use rice milk
someone else says to us kitkats you have
to use kitkats and somebody else says to
you it's all about celery we go to the
supermarket with all this good advice
from all these smart people with
brilliant case studies and we buy
everything we buy kit kats and m m's
celery and rice milk there's a lot of
time we spend at the supermarket and a
lot of money we spend at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout lane
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands and no one can see
what we believe because we bought
everything
but let's imagine we know our why let's
imagine our why is to always be healthy
and only do things that protect the
health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice from all the same smart
people this time we only buy celery and
we only buy rice milk they're the only
two that makes sense we spend less time
and less money at the supermarket and
when we're standing there in line with
only celery and only rice milk now
people can see what we believe
somebody walking past can say hey i can
see that you're healthy so am i you just
attracted an opportunity or a referral
or a friend simply by saying and doing
the things that you believe and the best
part is it's scalable
as soon as i said the why you knew
exactly which products we were going to
buy this means the more you can
articulate your why the more others will
know what you stand for and will be able
to help you make the right decisions
from now on you will work to ensure
everything you do is a good fit
if you do too many things that aren't a
good fit you'll feel uncomfortable and
people will feel that you're being
inauthentic
on the other hand when you start with
why
your ability to stand out find support
and work to all your natural strengths
will flourish
with practice you will learn to trust
your why
you will eventually start to see your
job and the things you do as ways to
breathe life into your cause
and the better you get at it the more
you will feel that your life and
everything you do has purpose
the best way to implement your why is to
work at it slowly you don't have to do
all the tips we suggest what is
important is that you pick up to three
and commit to practicing and using them
now what you'll find is that that um
the better you are at communicating your
why
um people will want to work for you uh
regardless of the opportunity that you
afford them like they want to be a part
of it yeah um we do a little thing which
we've been doing for years and years and
years called a give and take whenever
there's any kind of relationship whether
it's a
a an outside partnership or even uh
somebody who joins our team we do
something called a give and take where
we want somebody to be selfish and
selfless within the relationship
so not give and get but give and take so
we'll ask them what is it that you have
to give to us that you have that you
think that we need right and they'll
tell us and then we'll say great what is
it that you selfishly want from us and
we want them to tell us what they can
get from us
and when those when those things match
you have a balanced relationship because
so for example i've had it with people
you know they'll tell me what they what
they have to offer and that's awesome
because that's what i want and then
they'll say what they have what they
want to take and they go oh i want to
work with the smart people i'm like
plenty of smart people what is it you
want to take from me they're like oh i
want to help build something
wonderful do that anywhere what do you
want to take selfishly from me that you
can get nowhere else and if they can't
answer the question i won't engage in a
relationship and the reason is because
in time the relationship is unbalanced
they're going to be giving but they're
not taking and i don't even know how to
give them what they want then they'll
complain they're not making enough money
or because it's not balanced that's
right so there are five practices in
order to lead uh with an infinite
mindset
you have to have a just cause
you have to have trusting teams
you have to have a worthy rival you have
to have a capacity for existential
flexibility and you have to have the
courage to lead
so just cause we have to give our people
something to advance
a cause so just
that they would be willing to sacrifice
their interests in order to do so in
other words turn down a better paying
job or
frequent business trips or working late
hours and though i may not like those
things i do them because it feels worth
it because i believe in what i'm a part
of here because i feel that i'm helping
advance because there's no achieving in
the infinite game
the goal is not final achievement the
goal is advancing to progress in the
infinite game and to have that vision of
an idealized state of the world
that
all men are created equal right it's an
ideal that a nation is striving towards
that we'll never actually get there but
we'll die trying that's the point and we
can offer people the same thing inside
an organization in fact in fact we have
to um to give them something to advance
now how is this different from the
a y comes from the past it is an origin
story every single one of us has our own
unique why it is our birthright it comes
from the sum total of how we were raised
as kids it is objective you have one and
you have one for the rest of your life
the only one right and the rest of our
lives are about making the decisions
that help us uh keep in balance with our
why a just cause doesn't come from the
past it just causes about the future
it's about where we're going right you
can have multiple just causes you can
have one professionally you can have one
personally you can have one for your
family you can have one for your church
and we're involved in all of these
there's massive pressure put on people
especially young people to what's your
vision well we're not all steve jobs and
bill gates we're not all visionaries
we don't have to have a vision but we do
have to find a vision that we can find
someone else's vision and we are so
compelled by it that we want to make it
our own that's what it means to go work
for a company with a visionary leader
that we believe in that vision so
clearly that we take their vision and we
make it our own and we will happily
contribute our work our effort in order
to advance what is now my vision right
martin luther king had a vision he stood
on the steps of the lincoln memorial and
told us his vision but his vision became
our vision so i may not have come up
with that vision but i found it and i'd
like to devote time and energy to help
advance it even beyond him we all carry
a narrative
um
someone's lazy
um someone's stupid
someone doesn't care
someone's only in it for themselves
these are narratives that we carry and
the problem is when we evaluate their
behavior through our narrative we it'll
become it will become self-reinforcing
we will see the things that reinforce
our narrative
and the problem is then we'll treat them
that way if we've decided someone's lazy
we're going to treat them as lazy
so there's a great exercise to do which
is literally take out a piece of paper
and when we're struggling with someone
to think what are the 20 other things
that could be going on in their life so
yeah number one they're lazy possible
it's absolutely possible number two
they're having trouble in their marriage
number three
their um things have gone wrong and they
and they don't know how to ask for help
number four they're still struggling
with the trauma of kovid number five
their kids are flunking out of school
like all of a sudden
we realize there's a lot of other
reasons that could explain their
behavior and we will then treat them
accordingly we will treat them with
greater empathy
you know instead of walking into
someone's classroom and saying what the
hell you're you know your performance is
still down i've had this conversation
with you before you got to get your
performance up or i don't know what's
going to happen
or
you can walk into their classroom and
say
your performance is down we've had this
conversation before
are you okay i'm worried about you
we we they have a problem but they
aren't necessarily the problem and even
if ultimately it does become that they
were bad for the culture
they're still they are still not the
problem they still are just a bad fit
for the culture they have a problem we
can help them solve that problem by
going to help them relocate to a
different school district where they're
going to be so much happier we're going
to be so much happier everybody gets to
be so much happier so the other story i
was thinking of is the story of alan
mullally
when he took over ford
ford is losing money hand over fist in
other words performance was in decline
and when he sat down with his most
senior executives
and he asked for a report on how their
divisions were going regular green every
single one of them delivered powerpoints
with all green slides
and he said at the end of the meeting
how can everything be green
if we're losing billions of dollars
and they just sat there and he had
another meeting
same thing all green and he said the
same thing how can everything be green
if we're losing billions of dollars the
problem was the previous leader if you
delivered a red slide you got fired
and so there is no way that anybody was
going to tell the truth
because their job depended on it
and so one executive took the risk to
turn one slide red
and mullally said
thank you for the the the
the visibility that's great transparency
now how can we all help him fix that
problem he has a problem he is not the
problem
all the other executives thought he was
going to get fired
turns out he wasn't and slowly but
surely
everybody including leadership could
finally get a clear and transparent view
of what was actually going in their
organization and they worked together to
solve the problems if somebody was
struggling people said how can we help
you rather than i'm fine you're the one
that's screwing everything up so it's a
great way to think about it there's a
whole industry around i think work-life
balance is yeah it's like there's a
massive industry that's just trying to
teach this and help people with
work-life balance yeah the problem seems
like it's failing treating what's
treating a symptom isn't it you know
it's
you know it's like so many things in our
life
so here's the bad analogy
um
so we buy running sneakers and they have
really thick
you know this yeah they have really
thick heels tons of padding in the heel
right but that's because people don't
know how to run
right because we land with our heel
which is bad for our joints you know
you're not supposed to have an extended
knee yeah all of it you're supposed to
be a toe planter where your knees are
always bent i mean you know all this
yeah so instead of teaching people how
to run what we do is we just
build shoes with more padding in the
heel
and treat the symptom rather than the
cause right
and uh
i think it's it's the same thing
you know uh uh we we treat symptoms
instead of the cause
so
so so so the work like balance thing
what we're doing is instead of instead
of changing businesses instead of
changing the way a business operates and
changing the way in which we teach
leaders to operate with an infinite
mindset so that we more naturally have
work-life balance and let's be crystal
clear what work-life balance means you
know doing more yoga does not create
work-life balance right that's the
that's the shoe
that's the cushion on the shoe right
yeah the what what the
imbalances i feel safe at home i don't
feel safe at work that's the imbalance
and no amount of yoga or vacation time
is going to fix that what fixes that
work life imbalance is better quality
leadership in our businesses
and then what you'll find is the balance
but instead what we do is we have an
entire industry that's treating the
symptom that's putting that's putting
christian on the shoe to make us
feel
kinda for an hour right that i've
achieved balance
you know
but it's just for an hour
and you know we literally market you
know companies market themselves as
helping provide you work-life balance
unless you're teaching leaders to the
people who are my bosses then you are
not helping me achieve work like
mountains you're helping me numb the
pain helping me cushion the blow
dopamine is the feeling
uh that you've found something you're
looking for or that you accomplish
something you set out to accomplish so
you know that feeling you get when you
cross something off your to-do list
that's dopamine feels awesome you know
when you when you have a goal to hit and
you achieve that goal you're like yes
you feel like you've won something right
that's dopamine the whole purpose of
dopamine is to make sure that we get
stuff done
right
um the historical reason for dopamine we
would never eat
if we only waited to get until we got
hungry because there's no guarantee that
we would find food so dopamine exists to
help us go looking for food we get
dopamine when we eat which is one of the
reasons we like eating and so when you
see something that reminds you of
something that feels good we want to do
the behavior that helps us get that
feeling right so let's say you're out
there going for a walk and you see an
apple tree in the distance you get a
small hit of dopamine and then what it
does is it focuses us on our goals and
now we start walking towards the apple
tree and as the apple tree starts to get
a little bigger we feel like we're
making progress you get another little
shot of dopamine and another little shot
of dopamine until you get to the tree
and you're like yes
okay this is why we're told you must
write down your goals your goals must be
tangible there's a there's a biological
reason for that we we're very very
visually oriented animals you have to be
able to see the goal
for it to biologically stay focused
right if you don't write down your goals
if you can't see your goals it's very
hard to get motivated to get inspired
for example think about corporate
visions right a corporate vision is have
to be something we can see right that's
why it's called a vision
you can see it
right to be the biggest most respected
to be the fastest growing are not
visions they're nothing
right
what does that even look like respected
by whom your mother yourself your
friends your shareholders who knows
what's the metric done oh it's amorphous
doesn't motivate us
just like i can't tell you you will get
a bonus if you achieve more
you're going to ask me how much more
i'm going to say
more
doesn't work you need a tangible goal
you need a tangible goal right here's a
great vision
martin luther king i have a dream
that one day
little black children and little white
children will play on the playground
together and hold hands together we can
imagine that we can set our sights on
that and every time we achieve a goal
and achieve a metric and achieve a
milestone that makes us feel like we're
making progress to the go the vision we
can see we keep going and going and
going until we achieve something
remarkable you have to be able to see it
dopamine
like i said dopamine is the feeling you
get
when you set out to find something
you're looking for as well
talked about the to-do list i came home
from
a trip just a couple days ago and i had
a bunch of errands to run and i wrote
down a little list of things i had to do
and off i went right
and as i was walking past i think it was
a drag queen i don't remember i was
walking past something i remembered oh i
have to do that and i hadn't written it
down on my i hadn't written down on my
to-do list so i went in and finished
what i needed to do and then when i came
out i then wrote it on my to-do list and
then crossed it out
because i wanted the dopamine feels good
dopamine comes with a warning
dopamine is highly
highly
highly
addictive
here are some other things that release
dopamine
alcohol
nicotine gambling
your cell phone
oh you think i'm joking
okay we've all been told that uh you
know uh
if you wake up in the morning
and you crave a drink you might be an
alcoholic
well if you wake up in the morning the
first thing you do is check your phone
before you even get out of bed
you might be an addict
if you walk from room to room in your
own apartment holding your telephone
you might be an addict
when you're driving in your car and you
get a text and your phone goes beep
we we hate email true we love the beep
the buzz the ding oh
right
you'll be there in 10 minutes and yet
you have to look at it right now
you might be an addict and even if you
read it and it says are you free for
dinner next thursday and you have to
reply immediately you can't wait the 10
minutes
you might be an addict
and for all you gen y's out there who
like to think that you're better at
multitasking but you grew up with the
technology then why do you keep crashing
your cars when you're texting
you're not you're not better at
multitasking you're better at getting
distracted
in fact if you look at the statistics
add and adhd have
diagnoses of add and adhd have risen 66
percent in the past 10 years
okay add an adhd is a frontal lobe
disorder right are you telling me out of
nowhere 66 of our youth has the frontal
lobe problem
where did that come from no it's a
misdiagnosis right what what are the
what are the symptoms of a dopamine
addiction to technology distractibility
inability to
to get things done easily easily
distracted you know
shortness of attention it's all the same
thing so we misdiagnose things it's this
it's the addictive quality of dopamine
we can also get addicted to performance
in our companies when all they do is
give us numbers to hit numbers to hit
numbers to hit and a bonus you get and a
bonus you get and a bonus you get all
they're doing is feeding us with
dopamine and we can't help ourselves all
we do is want more more more it's no
surprise that the banks destroyed the
economy because one of the things we
know about dopamine addict is they will
do anything to get another hit sometimes
at the sacrifice of their own resources
and their relationships ask any
alcoholic gambling addict or or drug
addict
ask them how their relationships are
doing and if they've squandered any of
their resources it's an addiction
dopamine is dangerous
if it is unbalanced it is hugely helpful
when in a comfortable and balanced
system but when unbalanced
it's dangerous and it's destructive you
speak to businesses and companies and
leadership teams and employees and stuff
uh without mentioning names i don't want
to put you on the spot but have you gone
and talked to a company that's been in
trouble
and then spoken to their team and then
checked in on them after you've spoken
to their leadership team and what did
that look like did you notice a
noticeable change did they come to you
and tell you that this has helped our
organization out and our culture is much
improved because of it
you mean does my work
i mean
sure
here's the problem with my stuff
you got to do it
and i
am not i'm not anybody's like you know
mom or dad i'm not going to do it for
you and i have a very less fair approach
of it i once had a i once had a client
this is a
bunch of years ago that said
what guarantee do i have that your stuff
will work
to which my answer was none
like
i i'm giving you a tool
you can it's like a hammer you can use
it broadly or narrowly you can build a
table you can build a house it's the
same tool you can use it for marketing
you can use it completely revitalize
your entire culture and even though i'm
going to sell you the most beautiful
hammer i'm not going to guarantee the
structural integrity of the house
right it's your business you want to
ignore all my stuff ignore it i don't
care it's your and if your business
collapses you know what happens to me
nothing
like i don't mean to be cold about it
like of course i want the people i work
with to do well but it's not mine it's
theirs and i take no emotional
responsibility for the decisions they
make so yes there are many people that
i've had the pleasure of working with
some who worked for dysfunctional
organizations that went on the hard
journey of completely changing the way
they lead and completely revitalizing
their culture and it has great success
it's not because of me it's because of
them
right at the same time there are many
people who came in like what an amazing
speech and did nothing
you know thanks that was great you know
and i don't it's of course it's going to
fail
you know so i i think that we we have
too much
especially in the consulting world or
the design world everybody's so
paternalistic
about it and designers are famous for
this right they get so personally
offended when the client chooses the
wrong thing
oh there's such videos don't they know
we're trying to help them
or who cares
like it's their business
right that's what you find i've i've had
that instead of arguing with somebody
for them to make the right choice which
because we genuinely want to help them
what i have found is if you push the
accountability because when we argue
we're taking accountability this is
better this will help you
we're taking responsibility
accountability but if we say look
we've been doing this a bunch of years
we know more about design than you do
i'm telling you for every reason that i
can outline for you why this will help
you more
but if you don't want to do it that's
fine it's your business do what you want
the minute you switch the accountability
and put it all on them amazingly they're
much more open to your opinion
because now they're responsible we are
designed to take care of each other as
social animals it is in our biology that
we will take care of each other this is
why it feels so good when somebody does
something really nice for us with no
expectation of anything in return we've
all had the experience where somebody
does something nice and you're like oh
my god thank you and then they put their
hand out you're like oh it kind of like
ruins the whole experience completely it
ruins it but when they just
do it and they're like no no and you're
like please they're like no no it's my
pleasure yeah you know not only does our
esteem for them go up but it just it
feels good
likewise it feels good when we do
something for someone else with no
expectation of anything in return we
give our time and our energy money
actually doesn't work believe it or not
like if i told you i gave 500 to charity
this morning you'd be like
okay
that's great simon but if i told you
that last weekend i gave up my saturday
and went to painted schools in the inner
city you'd be like nice that's really
awesome right now the value of my labor
was worth a lot less than 500
and that's the point
right that's the point which is um
we are designed to take care of each
other and there's a chemical called
oxytocin
which is the chemical responsible for
our feelings of love and friendship and
trust when you look at somebody you
adore and you go like this that's
oxytocin when somebody touches you and
says oh my god it's so good to see you
touch creates oxytocin it's so good to
see you yeah you know it actually makes
us feel closer to each other you know
when oxytocin is released in our bodies
not only does it make us feel good not
only does it boost our immune systems
but the more oxytocin we have in our
bodies it actually makes us more
generous because the human body is
trying to get us look after each other
and it gets even better than that the
person who does the act of generosity
giving of time or energy without
expectation of anything in return they
get a shot of oxytocin the person on the
receiving end gets a shot of oxytocin
and even witnessing an act of generosity
or kindness releases oxytocin it feels
good to see somebody do something nice
and the more oxytocin we have in our
bodies as i said means we're more likely
to do something nice for somebody this
is the biology of pay it forwards it's
the human body's desperate attempt to
get us to look after each other
and so when we create environments where
we allow that to flow it does naturally
it just takes care of itself it's just
biology
when we create environments where we
restrict that it actually does the
opposite it releases a chemical called
cortisol which is the feeling of stress
and anxiety cortisol actually inhibits
oxytocin which means if we work in a
poorly led organization not only do we
have high stress
but we actually
it it actually inhibits empathy and in
other words i'm less likely to even want
to care about somebody because of the
poor leadership and the poor environment
that's been provided for me to work in
right and the more cortisol we have in
our bodies stress goes up anxiety goes
up it affects our immune systems happy
people live longer happy people have
lower rates of cancer diabetes and heart
disease which means when you're in a
position of leadership you're actually
medically responsible for the lives of
these people
get the environment right they will live
longer they will suffer lower cases of
disease and they will probably have
happier families because of it whereas
if you're a bad leader over the course
of time you're actually killing the
people working with you our jobs are
actually killing us leadership is a
responsibility
to people around us it's not a rank
um you've heard me say this before i
know many people who sit at the highest
levels of organizations who are not
leaders right they have authority and we
do as they tell us because they have
authority over us but we would not
follow them right and i know many people
as do you who sit
at lower levels of organizations who
have no formal authority and that
they've made a choice to look after the
person to the left of them and look
after the person to the right of them
and we would trust them and follow them
anywhere in other words leadership can
come from anywhere within or within an
organization yes we have the right to
demand to have better leaders and better
leadership
in our companies but when we don't
quitting is not the only option nor is
simply complaining but undertaking the
task of be becoming the leader we wish
we had wow you know anyone at any level
can can become a student of leadership
and anyone at any level can choose to
take
to to look after this person and that
person and work tirelessly to see that
they rise they become better versions of
themselves and that they show up to work
inspired and go home feeling fulfilled
and feel safe when they're at work what
i think is really interesting is think
of a date like uh uh like a job
interview right um and think of a job
interview like a date right so um if you
went on a on a first date with someone
and they sat down they said you know um
i'm extremely rich
um i've made lots of money i do lots of
cool things i've met a lot of famous
people
i go on tv all the time which is good
because i'm really good looking
uh yeah yeah
would you want to go on a second date
with them right not very appealing it's
also not very appealing when we sit down
for a job interview and just tell people
how great we are and all the things that
we've done it's the same kind of thing
now imagine if you knew your why
and you're making conversation with
someone
and they say so you know where are you
from would you know tell me a little bit
about you
and you say you know
i love what i do i love my life i love
my job you can say i i
i wake up every day to inspire people to
do the things that inspire them and for
me the challenge is finding all the
different ways that i could do it um and
i've been really really
grateful for the path that it's taken me
and i've i've made some money and i've
get to go on tv which is funny because
i'm really good looking and you can see
how all the same jokes and all the same
things now have a context and that's
what why does it provides context it
also helps you connect with somebody
that when somebody's telling you about
themselves and you ask some questions
and you get to know them a little bit
you realize that maybe their values are
completely different than yours so why
gives you clarity and confidence in who
you are and what you need around you um
but it also helps you present yourself
in a way that's way more authentic now
there's a there's a there's a rub to the
why that i don't talk about that often
because you really have to get good at
giving your why before you can deal with
this but the the difficult part about
knowing your why is the thing that you
give to the world the value you give and
offer to other people is also the thing
you need the most
so it's one so one of the ways to to
to
understand the people in our lives
partners and mates is can they actually
give us the thing that we give to other
people a lot of people think that um
this concept of why was some sort of
academic exercise that i went out and
studied it and i didn't that's not how
it began
as you said it began out of pain i owned
my own small business it was a strategic
marketing consultancy and superficially
my life looked pretty good i owned my
own business i made a decent living we
had incredible clients we did incredible
work except after a few years of doing
that
i sort of lost my passion for it i
didn't want to wake up and do it again
and i was actually very
embarrassed by that
because there were people who had real
problems like for me you know and so i
kept it to myself and i pretended all of
my energy went into pretending that i
was more successful happier and more in
control than i felt
um and it wasn't until a friend of mine
came to me and
sort of expressed concern like you're
different is everything okay and it
wasn't until i had sort of that safety
net of someone close by that i had the
courage to sort of not only face the
problem but but really confront it
um and and it was that that that was the
birth of this concept of why there was a
confluence of events and i realized that
every single organization including
including my own career functioned on
three levels what i did how i did it and
why i did it i knew what i did that was
easy to explain how i did it was also
pretty good i was good at explaining
what made me different or special than
others but i couldn't tell you why i was
doing it and it was that
that missing piece that i became
obsessed with and once i found my why
not only was my passion restored to
levels that i'd never experienced before
but it put me on a trajectory that i
couldn't have been on
without it
and i learned a lot of things from that
experience a lot i spoke at an education
summit for microsoft i also spoke at an
education summit for
apple
at the education for my at the education
summit for microsoft i would say that 70
of the executives spent about 70 percent
of their presentations talking about how
to beat apple
at the apple education summit a hundred
percent of the executives spent a
hundred percent of their
presentations talking about how to help
teachers teach and how to help students
learn
one is playing this way and one is
playing that way
one is playing finite
and the other one is playing infinite
gets which one gets frustrated
so at the end of my talk at microsoft
they gave me a gift they gave me the new
zune when it was a thing
and let me tell you
this thing was spectacular
it was the most elegant piece of
technology i'd ever used the user
interface was incredible the design was
spectacular i absolutely loved it it was
easy to use and it was bright and
gorgeous and it didn't work on itunes
which is a different problem so i
couldn't use it but but it was amazing
and elegant my god it was elegant
so i'm sitting in the back of a taxi
with a very senior apple executive sort
of employing number 12 kind of guy and
you know i like to stir pots so i turned
him i said you know
microsoft gave me their new zoom
and it is so much better
than your ipod touch
and he turned to me and he said
i have no doubt
conversation over
because the infinite player understands
sometimes your head and sometimes you're
behind
sometimes your product is better and
sometimes it's worse
the goal isn't to be the best every day
the goal isn't to out to out do your
competition every day that's a finite
construction if i had said to microsoft
i've got the new ipod touch and it's so
much better than your zoom they would
have said can we see it what does it do
react react react react
finite players play to be bet to beat
the people around them
infinite players play to be better than
themselves
to wake up every single day and say how
can we make our company a better version
of itself today than it was yesterday
how can we create a product
this week that's better than the product
we created last week we also have to
play the infinite game it's not about
being ranked number one it's not about
having more followers on twitter than
your friends
it's not about outdoing anyone it's
about how to outdo
yourself
it's not about selling more books or
getting more ted views than somebody
else it's about how to make sure that
the work that you're producing is better
than the work you produced
before
you are your competition
and that is what ensures you stay in the
game the longest and that is what
ensures you find joy
because the joy comes
not from comparison
but from advancement the next part is a
worthy rival
now i said before that the only true
competitor in an uh an infinite game is
yourself this is true what your
competition does is it helps reveal to
you your weaknesses
admire
the others in your organization not to
beat them there's no such thing not to
be number one there's no such thing but
if somebody else is better than you at
something that means you have to go work
harder yourself it's like running in a
race if you're driven to be number one
if you're driven to make the most money
if you're driven to show up in some
arbitrary ranking that you don't even
have a say in
that's like
tripping the the next runner you will
win the race but you're still a slow
runner
rather
fall behind this year and then you work
and work and work because ultimately the
goal is not to be number one this year
the goal is to create an organization
that will outlast every single one of
you
this is about building strong
foundations
this is about looking long-term in the
short term money is simply fuel to
to to uh to make the car go
we don't own cars to buy more fuel
we own cars to go somewhere
it's the same thing in an organization
your organization exists to advance
something
the money is simply there to make a go
and i fear
that what has happened in the university
system is similar to what i'm seeing
in
business
it's similar to what i'm seeing in
politics it's similar to what i'm seeing
in hospitals
which is an over
uh the sense of excessive pressure
to bring money in
at the expense of something else
there's an excessive amount of
short-termism
and massive amounts of rationalizing
this is just the game
we just have to do it if we don't
somebody else will
the obsession with getting grants
meaning you're hiring people who are
more likely to help you get a grant
even though they're teaching things that
we don't necessarily even need or want
that's called short-termism i'm a huge
modern dance lover like that's the thing
i love
and
i don't go to the joyce anymore
because everything that they have on
their stage is good
it's good
everything is safe to me
they put things on their stage that
that's good they sell tickets nothing's
bad
and nothing's great it's all good i
don't go anymore
i go to bam a lot i have seen things
that have profoundly changed my view of
the world and i have walked out of more
things at bam
literally i'm like i'm done
and my friend's like you can't i'm like
we can
you know
i have walked out out of so many things
at bam
and yet i continue to go and continue to
go and i continue to go because i know
what they stand for
that's my preference
i'm not saying it's right or wrong i'm
saying that's my preference
that i would rather take the risk of
walking out
knowing that i might get moved in a way
that i've never experienced before more
than just go and have a nice night out
and see something that i know is good
right and i think that goes for our
careers as well
you know which is
if you choose to be the kind of artist
that stands for something that you want
to be yourself and bring yourself into
everything that you do
you will get fewer parts
you will
the parts you get
will move you
in a way that most artists will not get
moved
or
you can bend and manipulate yourself a
little bit and sort of be a little bit
more of what they want
and play their role
and even though you don't really buy
into it it's a part and i want to be an
actor i want to be a performer i'm going
to i'm going to do what they want you
will absolutely get more parts without a
doubt you will you will can arguably
have a better career
but will you be profoundly moved as an
artist the odds are lower it's not i
can't say never it's just the odds are
lower it's not better or worse it is
simply the decision
on how you choose to manage or lead your
own career
both are acceptable right one means you
get to use your facility a lot
one means you get to work a lot one
means you might be able to do only your
art and actually make a living
one means that you're going to be
meeting a lot of people and the odds are
that you will connect with somebody at
some point
or
you choose this route
which is much more difficult
and is fraught with much more risk
and much more struggle
but you become known for the thing that
you are what do good leaders have in
common um they have the courage to do
the right thing
um they're people of of high character
and high integrity um but for me the big
one is courage it's it's very hard to be
a leader it's hard to speak truth to
power very often you might be the one
that gets in trouble or lose your job um
it's hard to do the right thing it's
much easier to do the expedient thing
um and um and it's also a huge
undertaking to be a leader every every
moment of every day it's
kind of like being a parent i was
watching the olympics this last summer
olympics and i was amazed at how bad the
questions were that the reporters would
ask all the athletes and almost always
they ask the same question whether they
were about to
compete or after they competed
were you nervous
right
and to a t
all the athletes went
no right and what i realized is it's not
that they're not nervous it's their
interpretation of what's happening in
their bodies i mean what happens when
you're nervous right your heart rate
starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty right you
have expectation of what's coming and we
interpreted that as i'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
olympic quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say as nervous
as excited they all say the same thing
no i'm not nervous i'm excited
and so i've actually practiced it just
to tell myself when i start to get
nervous that this is excitement yeah you
know and so where when you i used to
speak in front of a large audience and
somebody would say how do you feel i say
a little nervous
now when somebody says how do you feel
i'm like really excited actually
and it it came from just sort of telling
myself no no this is excitement
and it becomes a little bit automatic
later on um but it's kind of a
remarkable thing to deal with pressure
by interpreting what your body is
experiencing as excitement rather than
nerves
and it's really kind of effective it
makes you want to rush forward rather
than pull back and yet it's the same
experience vision
here's the here's a thing that's always
boggled my mind right
why is it on balance on balance not
always but on balance why is it that
small companies tend to be more
innovative than big companies right
small companies that are under-resourced
can't necessarily get the best and
brightest
they're going to go out of business any
day and yet there's they come with
brilliant ideas and big companies full
of resources full of amazing people
by the little companies that come up
with the good ideas that's usually how
big companies innovate they buy the
smaller ones right
um why is that why is it that the most
resource companies tend not and i think
it's a question of reality and what i
mean by that is small companies their
vision
is
is more distant than their grasp
right they have delusions of grandeur
we're going to change the world change
industries reinvent this reinvent that
we have no money and no people but so
what my point is is the grasp
is shorter than the vision
and i think what happens is as companies
get bigger and bigger and bigger with
more and more resources what they start
to do is one of two things either
their their visions become well within
their grasp and they don't readjust the
vision or they actually bring the vision
back to put within their grasps
right
make things very achievable difficult
but achievable
for vision to truly be vision it should
feel unachievable when a small business
gets together and says here's our vision
everybody goes like this
how are we going to do that
in big business we see here's a vision
every goes all right
yeah no got it we'll do a back plan
and i i firmly believe that innovation
is born out of the struggle innovation
is born out of the resourcefulness that
you're forced to figure out because
literally the vision is way beyond your
grasp regardless of how many resources
you have it should always feel
overwhelming and impossible take a group
of people with tons of resources to give
them a vision they're going to go
how do you create the environment where
people are going to thrive and create
those results that you're talking about
what does you're asking me the question
um uh what does it mean to be healthy
you're asking me the question what does
it mean to be a great parent like i
don't have five things to be a great
parent right
it's a lifestyle and it comes number one
with the commitment that i am
responsible for the life of another
human being the growth of another human
being the closest thing to leadership is
parenting you have to be an infinite
student of parenting you know you want
to be a parent you ask your friends you
ask your own parents you join groups you
read magazines you watch talks whatever
it is you're constantly consuming how to
deal with this constantly changing
challenge of being a parent and it's ups
and downs and successes and failures you
know and that's what it is leadership is
the same
leaders great leaders are students of
leadership no matter how achieved they
may be
they're still learning
and it's a lifestyle it's the lifestyle
of what i need to do to look after
people which includes things like
listening
learning how to give and receive
feedback
um learning how to have effective
confrontations how to discipline when
necessary in a way that's constructive
um
roam the halls get to know people
learning what it means to to ask
somebody questions how do you ask
questions
you know like some people are naturally
good at being curious about other human
beings and some people are uncomfortable
because they're introverts or whatever
socially awkward but we can learn
you know how do you learn to remember
people's names oh i'm bad at names no
you've just decided you're bad at names
we can learn to be good at names so that
when we walk down the hall and say hey
tom
oh my god he remembers my name it's a
nice feeling it's a lifestyle
it's a lifestyle there are many many
things we have to do and constantly work
on to be a great leader to create that
environment those of us who believe that
there's a better way to build a
corporate environment those of us who
believe that we're that it that that
that being able to say i love my job as
a right
it's a it's not a privilege it's not for
a lucky few who get to go home at the
end of the day it's like i love my job
right it's not some some lottery that
you win you know p you know you go to a
dinner party and you ask them to do like
your job and they go i love my job and
we go oh you're so lucky they didn't win
anything
right right
it's not luck right
we are entitled it is our it is our
god-given right
to love going to work why is that
because i think human beings are tribal
animals and all of us want to feel
inspired
we all want to feel like we're part of
something bigger than ourselves we all
want to have some sort of physical and
psychological safety whether it's at
home or work you know we we fear war we
fear crime and we we want to feel
psychologically safe at home we want
safety and at the end of the day every
human being on the planet
wants the feeling that i can provide for
myself and my family there's nobility
and work you know um
handouts
don't work and they and they destroy the
human ego yeah you know there's nobility
in being able to to do a hard day's
worth of work and and collect a paycheck
and when i do really well somebody says
good job here's a little extra for you
because you're a valuable member of the
tribe and we want to make sure that
we're incentivizing the behavior that
you're doing and the behavior you're
doing is you're taking care of something
bigger than yourself so how do you
define success
um i think success is is um
is seeing those around you work to their
natural best and creating momentum
for a vision towards a vision that will
last
beyond yourself
so a guy is driving a bus
for 20 years he's got to retire he's on
madison avenue in new york packed every
day is people getting on that bus and
getting off
he has two kids
wife lives in
queens he might call himself successful
another guy might be vice president of
that company
who would call himself unsuccessful
so is success what you make of it so
it's
so
success is defined it's success is a
feeling it's not a it's not a series of
check marks and goals i think people
define success as as finish lines you
know they well i ran a marathon i'm
successful the question is a why did you
run the marathon and what happens after
you've completed the marathon do you
just keep running marathons what happens
if you break your leg and you can no
longer run marathons you know we set a
lot of people set um financial goals i'm
successful when i make my first million
ah okay now i have to make my second
million it's success is a feeling and
and it's the feeling of contribution so
your bus driver in queens if he has
decided that his job as a bus driver is
to ensure that everyone who gets on his
bus
feels better about themselves because
they got on his bus and not another bus
and so he greets them with a smile he
says good morning he says goodbye
that people remember that that
that uh that ride that they took with
him
versus the this vice president of the
company who's made it about himself
and his financial goals he's the one
who's unhappy as opposed to seeing those
around him succeed and those around him
go home with a love of their their day
you know because they come to work in
his company every day so i i still
believe success and good leadership are
about service to others when are you at
your best
i'm at my best when i'm around people
who believe what i believe i know it
seems silly but um
i try very very hard to sort of stack
the deck you know to put myself in a
position of strength um so for example
you know somebody asked me just
yesterday have you ever had sort of a
bad you know engagement i was thinking
myself i'm like not really but it's not
because i'm some sort of sort of genius
only saying anything like that it's
because i stack the deck it's because i
want to be there i want to be around
people who want me there in other words
if i'm somebody's tenth choice and like
you know i'll probably turn it down
whereas if i'm their first choice they
really want me there and so i'm more
likely to have a good engagement they're
supportive of me i'm supportive of them
and so
yeah i'm at my best when i when i stack
the deck when i choose to be in an
environment where my strengths are are
there nelson mandela is
a particularly special case study in the
leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but nelson mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father
to tribal meetings
and he remembers two things when his
father would meet with other elders
one
they would always sit in a circle
and two
his father
was always the last to speak
you will be told your whole life that
you need to learn to listen i would say
that you need to learn to be the last to
speak
i see it in boardrooms every day of the
week even people who consider themselves
good leaders who may actually be decent
leaders will walk into a room and say
here's the problem here's what i think
but i'm interested in your opinion let's
go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard
it gives everyone else the ability to
feel that they have contributed
and two you get the benefit of hearing
what everybody else has to think before
you render your opinion
the skill is really to keep your
opinions to yourself if you agree with
somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying
and at the end
you will get your turn
it sounds easy it's not
practice being the last to speak
that's what nelson mandela did there's a
brilliant
leader by the name of david marquez
who wrote a book called turn the ship
around and he had an experience as a
submarine captain on the uss santa fe
where
he realized that as much as he knew
about submarining you know he'd been a
submariner his whole career
that put on this new submarine he
learned the hard way that he actually
didn't know how the submarine worked he
he made an order that nobody knew how to
do it because there was that didn't
exist on that sub
and so he realized he had no choice but
to trust his people and he went through
this transformation as a leader of
telling everybody what to do to allowing
people to tell him what should be done
and i've learned a lot from him and i
highly recommend his book um
and uh and i i've i've really learned
that which is
you know at the top of the organization
as david says the people have all the
authority the leaders have all the
authority but at the bottom they have
all the context
right and so
you can't just push all the context up
you have to push the authority down
um and so the responsibility of
leadership is to train people make sure
that they have the skill set help build
their confidence that that they have the
confidence to do what needs to be done
they have to have competence and
confidence right and
that's that's your job that's the only
job of the leader makes it's like like a
parent make sure they have competence
and confidence you know make sure your
kids get schooling and make sure that
they believe in themselves and then
leave them
you know
and so i've i've done the same thing
instead of sort of showing people how i
would do it i want them to learn how
it's done you know and feel good about
themselves and then just however they do
it is how they do it yeah you know um
and the result is remarkable um people
feel better about coming to work they
feel like they have something to
contribute they feel more valuable
as opposed to just being told this is
how i would do it or i'm going to do it
this way
or do it my way
so yeah um
completely changing my understanding of
my job
as
um more like a parent than a
manager
has had remarkable impact why do you
prioritize serving the greater good in
doing what you do it's easy to pull
things back it's very hard to ramp
things up and i'd rather start with
something that's too big and pull it
back into reality then start with
something that's so easy that you can't
really get it up um
for example you know
don't set your goals realistically set
them entirely unrealistically i mean
shoot for 80 and be disappointed when
you hit 70 as opposed to shooting for 20
in being ecstatic when you hit 21. we
beat our goal yeah but it was a low goal
you know i think
i think to be
frustrated and achieving something
rather than ecstatic and and achieving
less is a better way to live
not to mention you achieve more
um
so
uh
i'm a great believer in that the greater
good
like those things are like so big
they're ridiculous i mean like
you know my goal is a 100 year goal is
called world peace
you know
so
daunting
you know but that's the idea if i fail
and i certainly won't achieve it in my
lifetime
i like to think that what i'll
contribute towards that ridiculous
idealistic nonsense goal
will be more than if i say if i can just
be happy by myself in my little house
you know right right i mean that's nice
and all but
that's good i like the idea of
contributing to your neighbor as well
when i discovered this thing called the
why um i realized it's power it had a
remark a remarkable influence over my
life and i
i loved sharing it i mean you know what
it feels like you know
the obsession with sharing the the ideas
haven't hasn't gone away i was obsessed
with it and i understood that i was the
only mouthpiece for it
and it was at a time when you know now
people talk about purpose and business
like it's no biggie back then it just
wasn't a thing it was like this you know
big idea
and then those who talked about it were
like weird hippie dippy types you know
it wasn't a mainstream thing yet um and
so i realized the power of the idea and
i made a conscious decision that i was
gonna you know everything comes at a
cost there's no there's nothing for free
whether it comes at a cost of money or
personal life or time or energy whatever
it is everything costs something you
know um
and so
uh i made the choice that i was going to
put myself out there and i was going to
drive this message as hard as i could
and i made a deal with myself that i
would drive hard until i achieved
momentum and i define momentum as if i
were to give less energy the message
would continue to spread the same or
faster without me
right in other words building a movement
where other people could spread the
message as well and the sacrifice i made
was
i wasn't at home
and so for a long period of time i was
undateable you know an amazing i'd meet
someone amazing
and i'd be like oh my god i had such a
great time are you free for a second
date in six weeks you know it's like
number one
he wants to date me and plus when i
would come home
[Music]
when i come home from a trip i'd be
exhausted so i just want to stay home
yeah so i knew that that was happening
and the nice thing is i'm the the
momentum is
like it has its own momentum yeah and so
now i'm i'm i'm i'm sticking to my deal
and then sort of um slowing down the
amount of time that i'm actually on the
road yeah okay so now you're looking for
better ways and different ways to spread
the message i realized that what i was
experiencing was an unfulfilled career
or an unfulfilled life compressed and
exaggerated into a 24-hour period
because i had an amazing day i had an
incredibly exciting experience i didn't
want to wake up and do it again i was
full of regret i didn't i was regretted
saying yes to this i didn't want to be
there i felt totally out of control
and i realized
you know a lot of people confuse
excitement with joy or they confuse
happiness with fulfillment you know our
careers and our jobs can be exciting and
fun and winning the new client and
making a big sale but that doesn't mean
we're fulfilled that doesn't mean we're
inspired that doesn't mean we have joy
in our lives and i realized this was the
mistake i had made
and so i'm in the purpose business you
know i realized that i felt this way
because i didn't have a sense of purpose
and so i tried to invent one you're here
to tell their story and come back and it
worked for like a minute and then it
would wear off
and i had i ran out of solutions i was
paranoid i was scared i was depressed i
was out of control and i had no solution
and so i lay in that bed and i gave up i
just i gave up i had i had nothing else
and
having given up i decided that if i'm
gonna get stuck here i might as well
make myself useful
and so i was going to volunteer to speak
anywhere and as often as they wanted me
to
to help out some of the amazing people
that i'd met i don't care if i had to
carry heavy boxes or sweep floors it
didn't matter how menial i wanted to
serve those who served others
and upon
making that decision this amazing calm
came over me um
an excitement even i was excited to now
be there and i couldn't wait to get to
work there are two currencies in the
infinite game will and resources
resources is money you need money to
stay in the game but you need the will
of the people as well and um the problem
is is that when we organize to win that
means the score is more important than
the inspiration and motivation than
people have to to give their blood sweat
and tears um and when we prioritize
resources before will that's a problem
i've never met a ceo that doesn't
believe their people are important the
problem is where on the priority list
you know
we've been to any number of
uh
presentations where they put their
priorities on the wall you know number
one growth number two shareholder value
number three our customer number four
our employees there it is see i do care
about our people
and the reality is as social animals we
want to work for and we're willing to
give our blood sweat and tears to
leaders who understand that the balance
of those two essential
currencies the balance of those two
things is will has to come before
resources and that doesn't mean 90 10
when i talk about putting people before
profit you know people freak out which
is ridiculous you need fuel for the car
to go money is fuel for the organization
of course even if there's a leaning it's
5149 there has to be a slight leaning
towards people because there will always
be decisions that a company has to make
in which those two cannot uh
both be supplied and one will have to be
sacrificed the question the question is
which will you always prioritize
let me give you a hypothetical example
to make my point two ceos the first ceo
says our number one priority is growth
and of course our people are important
because if we take care of our people we
will meet and exceed our financial goals
second ceo says
our number one priority is our people
and if we take care of our people we
will always meet and exceed our
financial goals which one would you
rather work for i don't want the product
i mean it's obvious right it's obvious
um so this is what it means to
prioritize will of resources it has of
course of course uh
money matters um but the people matter
more this is the practice of empathy
that if we're struggling to communicate
to someone every struggling to help
someone be at their natural best i'm
tired of people saying to me how do i
get the best out of my people really
that's what you want they're like a
towel you just ring them how can i get
the most out of them no how do i help my
people be at their natural best
right we're not asking these questions
we are not practicing empathy we have to
start by practicing empathy and relate
to what they may be going through and it
will profoundly change the decisions we
make it will profoundly change
the way we see the world first of all i
don't like the term failure i like the
term falling i think you need
we we fail fast well
the problem with the word fail is it's
like the word cancer right
if you have stage four lung cancer or
stage four liver cancer and you have a
mild melanoma
with a 99.9
chance of you'll be fine
both of those things are called cancer
and the problem is they're not the same
thing and failure is the same is the
same which is failure could be
absolutely catastrophic or it could be a
minor hiccup but the problem is we call
it failure so i think we need to use
different terms right failure i believe
is something we want to avoid but
falling is something that happens
naturally and we want to fall and get
get up more often that's what i think is
fall fast and get yourself back up as
opposed to lying on the ground and
complaining right so i i want to embrace
falling because that's that's taking
risks that's trying you only fall when
you push the boundaries right
but the the the the language matters
because it changes our mindset
especially because it's too broad a
definition for failure so one of the
ways we embrace falling
is by when somebody does fall we don't
say what have you done we go okay try
again
as leaders
right um or um how can i help you fix it
and we just a little more relaxed about
it and and we don't swoop in and do it
for them right
but rather we go
so in other words we're encouraging
risk-taking we're encouraging people to
try recognizing that they won't lose
their jobs
that
that
especially if you're more junior you
really couldn't do anything that brings
down the firm anyway
and we have to give people the
opportunity to fall and let them either
learn to fix their own problems or guide
them so that so that they can every
single one of us has screwed up a
bazillion times the only reason we are
where we are today is because somebody
said all right all right you're an idiot
but try again you know
like that's where i know who did it for
me peter and tomaszio my old boss years
and years and years ago the guy would
never answer any of my questions peter
what should i do what do you think we
should do like
if i knew i wouldn't be asking well what
do you think i think we should do this
then do that the guy never answered a
question and if i screw up he goes
what are you going to do
you know
but i never felt fear that i would get
fired ever
i never felt afraid that my job was on
the line when i screwed up
we have to do that existential
flexibility is the willingness to make
profound strategic shifts in order to
advance your cause 180 degrees right
this is not the daily flexibility that
you need in business um a leader or even
us as individuals um
may never have to perform an existential
flex
um
and at most you might ever have to do it
in an entire career once or never but
the responsibility of the of any leader
is to prepare their organizations for an
existential flex should it need need to
happen so what is an existential flex um
so the best case is really uh steve jobs
um and his just cause uh jobs and
wozniak had a very clear just cause
which is to empower individuals to stand
up to big brother right they're
revolutionaries at heart and they saw
the personal computer as a brilliant
tool to help them advance that to
empower individuals to stand up to to
big brother and steve wozniak imagined a
time in which an individual could
compete in business against a
corporation thanks to a personal
computer
impression right
um
apple's already had success from the
apple one the apple ii it's already a
big company steve jobs is already a
famous ceo and in december of 1979 jobs
and a bunch of his senior executives go
and visit xerox park which was xerox's r
d division
and xerox shows them
a new invention of theirs called the
graphic user interface
that allows a user to click a mouse on a
desktop to move icons and folders
to use the computer instead of having to
learn an entire computer language now
jobs
who believes in empowering
individuals sees this technology
and says to his team we have to invest
in this graphic user interface thing
and the voice of reason i guess in the
team says steve we can't
we can't do it we've already invested
millions of dollars in countless
man-hours in a different strategic
direction if we suddenly change
directions we're going to blow up our
own company
to which jobs actually said better we
should blow it up than someone else
and that decision led to the macintosh
um the first properly graphic user
interface computer that had in mass
market appeal um that was so profound
um that the entire
platform of windows windows 2.0
was basically designed to act like a
macintosh you know and the reason we all
have computers on our desks today the
reason it's a household appliance the
reason any one of us can compete against
a corporation
is because of this profound shift
he was willing to do that now i call it
a capacity for existential flexibility
because it's not shiny object syndrome
which you know too many entrepreneurs
are subjected to you know this is it
this is it guys you know flavor of the
moment
um
it's done with the very specific reason
of advancing the cause i found a better
way to advance the cause
and you have to have the just cause
otherwise how do you know what to shift
and you have to have the trusting teams
because you will put the organization
through short-term hell and that and the
numbers probably will go down in the
short term and the team has to be
willing to say
we agree
we understand why you're making the
shift let's do this and it's going to
suck
but
we're in and they hunker down and they
figure it out
if you don't have a just cause you're
literally just chasing something
and
if you don't have the trusting teams
this happens a lot where sometimes the
leader has the just calls but the team
doesn't know it
and if you don't have the trusting teams
then people will think you've lost your
mind and they'll start abandoning ship
or you respond to the pressures from
wall street or outside because the
numbers start to go down
um
but but uh existential flexibility like
i said if you don't have to do it you
have to prepare the organization for the
for your success for your successor to
be able to do it which means keep the
cause alive and and maintain the the
trusting teams human beings homo sapiens
been on this planet 50 000 years ish
right and for 40 of those 50 000 years
literally four fifths of our our time on
this planet we lived in populations that
were
uh never larger than about 150 people
and we didn't all live on top of each
other and they were communities
um and the way we survived in these
dangerous times we took care of each
other you know we contributed some
people built things some people hunted
for things some people made food some
people we took care of the kids with
their families and um and and the wealth
was distributed um
um you know there's there's there's
evidence they found in anthropological
digs where the best cuts of meat which
you would think would go to all the
alphas because i'm the strongest i get
to choose the food first you know
the best cuts of meat which they can
tell by the bones are actually
distributed amongst the tribe in other
words the the alphas the leaders yes
they were entitled to eat first that's
just the way we are we're hierarchical
animals you know nobody has a problem
that somebody
more senior nobody has a nobody has
visceral contempt for the idea that
somebody more senior in an organization
makes more money than me we're okay with
our alphas getting better treatment yeah
you know nobody has a problem with
celebrities you know
making more money
getting getting a table in the
restaurant that we have to wait for
right we're okay with it you know it's
it's one of the reasons we all try and
you know increase our our standing in in
in society by doing good and you know
hopefully you do it in a good way not
just getting you know internet famous
which is getting fame without any
contribution to society different
subjects right um but it was it was a it
was um
it was shared hardship shared sacrifice
for the good of each other you know that
doesn't mean there wasn't ego and
selfishness of course but at the end of
the day we needed each other yeah and
then about 10 or 12 000 years ago when
we started farming
we didn't need to travel anymore we
could stay put
and we could also sustain much larger
populations
than about 150
because we could because we could amass
resources this also allowed for ruling
classes and intelligence and things like
that you can have an entire group of
people who didn't hunt and didn't gather
they just governed
you know
like it's a ruling class that's what it
is or they just thought about
they became philosophers yeah like you
could we we had the resources for that
and we were okay with it and it's a good
thing because look at the advancements
in modern society in the past ten
thousand years simply because we we
couldn't we you didn't have to go toil
in the field you you could actually go
invent something you could innovate you
could innovate right so it's a good
thing but scale breaks things for human
beings
you know we're not naturally made for
living in large populations
and so the way it works best is when
when we when we organize into smaller
groups which is why hierarchy matters
which is why leadership training matters
so you asked about is the top person
responsible no the top person is
responsible for taking care of the
people
in their direct responsibility and
ensuring that they are charged with and
incentivize to take care of the people
you know with their direct
responsibility who are charged with and
incentivize to take care of the people
in their direct responsibility and the
people on the front lines are actually
doing all the work feel taken care of
and
[Music]
and are happy to contribute there's a
marine that i know
who's a marine general who says the way
he can judge the quality of a lieutenant
is he listens he listens to how the
the troops talk about their lieutenant
so when he's not around wouldn't is it
is it the lieutenant or is it our
lieutenant they take possession
of their leader wow right that's our
lieutenant
right versus that's it's always the
colonel it's never our colonel it's
always the colonel because there's no
relationship it's too too distant
right
so as soon as we take possession
emotional possession of our leaders
there's a there's a sign of devotion and
mutual trust but that relationship
starts with how the leader leads
yes we have a responsibility to give
back but we call you leader not because
you have the rank we call you leader
because you took the risk to trust first
we you you took your we call you leader
because you took the risk to build the
relationship first you took the risk to
create the circle of safety first you
took the risk to go head first towards
the vision first that's why we call you
leader because you undertook an element
of risk
you literally lead you went first right
nothing to do with rank the biggest
lesson i learned was thank goodness i
learned it pretty early on which is
and i think a lot of
business owners make this mistake
um
which is uh because i was the boss you
know in my own mind yeah um uh i thought
i had to know all the answers
and if i didn't i thought i had to
pretend that i did
and
uh
that's stupid
um
and
what i learned is that just because i
may have the the top position in the
hierarchy
i i'm not expected to know everything
and if i pretend to know everything it
diminishes the value of all the great
ideas and the great intelligence around
me and when things got difficult i would
never admit it right i would just put on
a brave face and show up every day and
um
and the the biggest lesson i learned was
to say i don't know i don't understand
or i need help
um
at any level about any subject yeah and
amazingly i was always surrounded by
people who wanted to help or who knew
answers but they never offered to help
or offer the answers because they didn't
think i needed it because i kept
pretending that i knew it all right not
to mention the fact that nobody likes a
no at all um
so that was huge for me and and when i
was willing to ask for help and accept
it when it was offered and and sort of
accept the humility of the fact that
other people know a lot more about a lot
of things than i know
i know one thing you know and they know
lots of things
um
uh that's when things really started to
move because we were now a team like we
were actually working together how would
someone know if they're doing something
for their why how do you know oh you can
feel it you feel it do you ever have
that experience where um you feel like
something's wrong you know sort of
you're like you make a decision but it
makes you uncomfortable you're not
you're not following through with your
cause or your purpose and you have to
ever have a decision where everybody's
like you're crazy you're crazy like this
just feels like the most natural normal
thing i could do i'm not even in doubt
here you know right now the problem with
simply running on gut is it's not
scalable this is the reason we want to
learn our why learn to articulate and be
able to speak our why so that others can
understand
why we're making the decisions we're
making because the problem is if you
only trust your gut to those around you
sometimes it does appear that we're
crazy or unfocused and so people leave
us and don't help us because they think
we're nuts
the minute we can articulate and speak
that why with clarity that others can
understand then not only will they have
context for the decisions we're making
but they'll rally to help us and even do
things that we didn't even ask because
they understand
the higher purpose that we're trying to
advance so
you just know it's a terrible answer um
but you can feel it and this is where
joy and fulfillment in our work come
from which is different from happiness
you can win a big client get a promotion
get a raise happy you know do a good job
produce something great happy but that
feeling dissipates it doesn't last for
you know it certainly doesn't last for
months or years it might last for days
or weeks right that that immensely happy
feeling that we all have that big client
we won or that big promotion we got is
now gone
joy fulfillment which doesn't mean that
we love every day but joy and
fulfillment comes from that feeling that
every day our work is contributing to
something bigger and that's that's way
more important also at least as
important so the infinite game exists up
here
finite game exists down here
right the infinite game is
includes the y what i call our purpose
cause or belief
it's the vision of the company it's
where we're going it's something that we
will never practically reach in our
lifetimes or ever
but we will die trying that's the point
right it's different from a big hairy
audacious goal which for all practical
purposes you could reach it may be
difficult but you could reach it this is
an ideal
something it's a vision of the world so
my vision i imagine a world in which the
vast majority of people wake up every
single morning inspired to go to work
feel safe when they're there and return
home fulfilled at the end of the day
that is my vision right
we will never practically get there but
we will die trying the united states was
founded with a document called the
declaration of independence in which the
document stated all men are created
equal
now the united states has not achieved
that and will never achieve that
but it the country is at its best when
we're trying to achieve that civil
rights women's suffrage gay rights the
you know universal education universal
health care etc etc
this is where our values exist
our values are timeless they do not
change every year whenever we have a
strategic offsite and if they do you
have a problem
that happens in big companies
every few years a new ceo comes in and
they have a values thing and they change
and they change and they change no no
your values are your values right
and they're based on your founders and
they exist from patterns
uh of how you operate when you are
operating at your natural best when your
company is operating at its natural best
when all cylinders are firing when
you're in the flow whatever euphemism
you want to use there is a pattern that
emerges and that pattern are your values
there's a minimum of three there's no
more than five if there's more than five
there's usually redundancy you can find
overlap that you can find lowest common
denominators and they are intractable
these things are inherently intangible
and hard to measure
right
which is why they often get brushed
aside it's not that they don't exist
they're just hard to measure
then down here you have the finites what
i call the what it's all the tangible
stuff
right things like our interests
exist down here because they are
tangible they are inherently easy to see
and easy to measure like products sold
money taken in things like that right
number of clients we have
the way you build an infinite business
is you want to run all decisions first
through your values and your cause and
then
through your interests that's how it
works
look
we make time for the things that matter
to us yeah um and
and
of course i have regrets but but regrets
is not i wouldn't use the word regret
of course there are things that i missed
and but i made a choice and i'm very
happy with that choice and i stand by
that choice because not only have i had
the opportunity the amazing experience
to spread this message and see it
actually grow and be bigger than me but
i'm it's i've i've had the opportunity
to live an absolutely surreal life
because of it my life profoundly changed
course
and i cannot
i can't it's not fair to compare those
things they're not equals yeah you know
you know everybody with straight hair
once curly hair and they were the curly
ones straight hair yeah once before i
mean i know people who have
the stability in the home life and the
families and look at my life and be like
oh my god i wish i had that and you look
at my life and i'm bouncing all around
and
i mean it's the answer is i'm really
grateful
for the life that i live so no regret is
not the word that i would use but there
was a price and a call there's a price
that it costs that i that i took
willingly these people always complain
that why can't i ever get that and these
people complain i can never get a job
you're gonna be stressed no matter what
focus on the thing that you're getting
because that's the choice you made right
i'd rather much rather you focus the
thing you you you're you're pursuing
rather the thing you're missing
and so this idea of affirmative thinking
positive thinking is essential for all
people but i think it's especially
essential for artists and there's a very
very simple
biological reason for it
which is the human brain
cannot comprehend the negative
it is incapable
yes it's true
i'll give you an example
[Music]
okay no no i'll give you an example you
don't have to believe me
i'll prove it
i'll prove it okay the human brain
cannot comprehend the negative you ready
don't think of an elephant
you can't you can't tell the human brain
not to do something right and so what
happens is we very often reinforce
things
when we put things in the negative
right i can't get apart
i can't get apart
i can't get apart right or
um
i can't do this
versus i'm going to keep doing this
i'm going to keep doing this
i'm going to keep doing this
right
um
and and it's such a huge thing to to
convert things into the affirmative
you're supposed to do with children as
well we're supposed to say instead of
saying to children
don't eat on the couch we're supposed to
say eat at the table
right we tell people what we want them
to do not want them what we don't want
to do pilots know this
right it is well known in the pilot
community that when you tell a pilot
don't hit the obstacle they'll hit the
obstacle
because what they're doing is focusing
on the obstacles yeah so i i went to
this uh event and just by sheer
coincidence at the dinner i'm sitting
next to dawn and sam goldwurm who run
this company called 1229 and that's
exactly what they do
dawn is a master nose
who used to work for cody the perfume
company so you produce all the famous
perfumes that we all know
and they want to start their own company
where they design custom sense for
brands
but the way to think about this is
beyond sort of verbena and patchouli
the way dawn explained it to me is
there are seven notes on the musical
scale
and you can
play chopsticks or you can play a
beethoven symphony it's the same seven
notes that's what you do with it and she
does the same thing with smell which is
you can have simple smells or you can
have highly complex ornate orchestras uh
symphonies rather and so they sat down
with me and took me through a fantastic
process and they produced the smell of
optimism
and it's the most beautiful thing and
the idea was born out of the fact that
i'm sitting next to this event and i
turned them and said have you ever sent
it a book has that ever been done before
and they said no it's never been done i
said well we should really do that
and so of course my publisher was not
excited to hear about that but but it's
the first time that i know that a book
has ever been centered in this way so it
is a scented book
the smell of optimism
uh is what you start with and it sets
you on your journey to enjoy the rest of
the book i'll ask you a very simple
question
why does your organization
exist
we don't need you clearly there's plenty
of competition clearly people have
plenty of choices
even the things that you may specialize
in there are others that do a reasonably
good job they might even be better than
you in some areas so why do you exist
providing education is table stakes
everybody here does that you can't rely
on that that's why the industry exists
not why your organization exists
that's like when i talk to healthcare
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy like no kidding
thank you
but i know that the culture of one
organization is different than the
culture of another organization
there are cultural norms that wrap
around the sense of purpose cause or
belief
great organizations understand their
just cause a cause so just
that people would be willing to
sacrifice to see the advancement of that
cause sacrifice comes in many forms it
might mean
working longer hours giving you my best
ideas turning down a better job that
offers me more money to stay here
because i believe in what you're doing
and i want to see that advanced
one of my favorite
examples of a just cause
is
the declaration of independence
our founding fathers
declared literally wrote down they
declared why
we needed our own country
all men are created equal endowed with
these unalienable rights amongst which
include life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness
they were never against britain
the whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
they won independence there are always
finite games within the infinite game
though they won independence
that didn't mean that they had now
provided all men are equal now the real
heavy lifting began
now let's be crystal clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white protestant men let's be
crystal clear
but even early on during the
revolutionary war george washington
understood how limiting that was and he
realized that they had to have a broader
definition
so he included catholics
he banned any organizing against
catholics and his armies and he would
regularly attend mass to send the right
message
some time later
we abolish slavery
and the 14th amendment
some time later we had women suffrage
sometime later we had
civil rights act sometime later we
implement gay rights and you can see
that we are striving
to provide this thing called all men are
equal people are equal and though we
will never actually get there we will
die trying and the obstacles may always
be different
and what a just cause is
it is a vision of the future that does
not yet exist and you will commit all of
your energies
to advance that vision of the world that
you have
and the people you want to attract both
those who work there those who teach
there and both those who come to learn
there
believe in your vision of the future
so much so
that they may turn down a better offer
from someone else
because they want to be
around people
who are committed to building this world
that does not yet exist and every single
single one of these organizations that
you
run and represent
can have different visions or
overlapping visions of the world but you
must be clear what your just cause is
what you stand for otherwise the only
thing i have to judge you on
is
superficial things
it's like dating right
it's like dating if if somebody tells me
what they stand for who they are they're
talking about their character
and those are the people we want to
spend the rest of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are what they stand for what their
purpose what their cause what their
beliefs are what their values are
the only thing we have to judge them on
is how much money they make and how good
looking they are working at a
at a hard job working for a bad boss can
sometimes be one of the greatest
educations ever so
the question is can we can you change
your mindset
instead of waking up in the morning
going oh i can't do this again but
rather viewed as university you know
you're getting a master's degree in
leadership and you might be learning
everything how not to do things and you
to wake up in the morning be like what
am i going to learn today
early on in my career i had i had a
really bad boss who believed that she
could get the most out of us by berating
us and and
she told me once that i had one of my
reviews and she said you have no talent
and i was like
nothing and she was like nothing this
was her way of i guess motivating me um
but i had such a good attitude about it
for a couple of reasons one because i
knew i knew what i was up against every
day and instead of taking it personally
i viewed it as as my education of how
not to lead and i literally would file
this stuff all the way and use it
someday i get to use it now um and also
misery loves company you know i had
fantastic a fantastic relationship with
my team we looked after each other
because we all had this this oppressive
boss we would compare the advice that we
got in our in our uh
in our little career building sessions
um
and uh and we took care of each other
and so we had a responsibility to each
other and that's where we cut our teeth
on being leaders and it actually made
the job wonderful yes there were days
that were oppressive yes there were days
that i hated yes there are days i want
to like pull my hair out and just quit
but
it's because of the team that i had that
we looked after each other and the
mindset of learning every day that i
that i made the most of it so i i think
mindset is a huge huge huge part of
actually getting some joy out of a
difficult job
the thinking of milton friedman the the
1970s economist
has really dominated sort of business
theory today he theorized that the
responsibility of business this is his
definition the responsibility of
business is to maximize profit within
the bounds of the law right he
what about ethics
you know like a a pharmaceutical company
that raises the price on essential drug
200 300 500 800
it's not illegal
it is unethical right it makes us
uncomfortable and yet the law
is not broken that's not a good enough
standard to run a business
um and it was his thinking that gave
rise to the the theory of shareholder
supremacy which was a theory proposed in
the late 1970s
where we prioritize the once needs and
desires of a shareholder over the needs
of the customer or the employee which is
like a coach who's trying to build a
great team by doing what the fans want
versus what the players need right
that's basically shareholder supremacy
and as i said it was just a theory
proposed in late 1970 that was
popularized
during the boom years of the 80s and 90s
mass layoffs where we use
the livelihoods of human beings to meet
arbitrary projections on an annualized
basis at the end of the year
did not exist did not exist as a
standard business practice prior to the
1980s did not exist it was popularized
doing during the 80s and 90s
the dismantling of glass-steagall which
was an act passed after the great
depression to prevent another great
depression from happening and by the way
was extremely effective
between the dismantling of the
glass-steagall in the 80s and 90s and
the great depression there were a total
of zero stock market crashes since then
dismantling all in the name of corporate
profit we've had three we had uh the
dot-com boom black monday in 2008.
in other words when we play simply with
a finite mindset we actually do
long-term damage to our own system
that's supposed to benefit uh all of us
um and and and i find that upsetting um
we've seen the rise of of of milton's uh
friedman's thinking rather
and like i said his theories dominate
business today and we feel it not only
have we had those those stock market
crashes but anybody who goes to work
today there's a general feeling of
unease you know especially if you work
for a company that embraces
annual or even quarterly layoffs to meet
arbitrary projections keep in mind a lot
of the companies that employ
mass layoffs are profitable just not as
profitable as they would like it's not
like they're losing money and they had
to do this to save the sinking ship
that's something completely different
these are highly profitable companies
that missed a projection and so they
laid people off so they could meet that
projection there's something
fundamentally wrong with that
and we know it because we feel it at
work we see this decline of trust we are
not loyal to our companies anymore why
would we be they're not loyal to us
and leaders set the tone so when
companies are loyal to us we will give
loyalty back to them when they're not
loyal to us why would we be loyal to
them
i'm tired of
of ceos telling me that you know
millennials these days don't stick
around very long well why would they if
you don't offer them any kind of loyalty
uh back and it's not for the people to
prove to you that they're loyal it's the
other way around when i wrote leaders
eat last that that book
i mean it was a it was a behemoth yeah
and
uh
i had you know nights and weekends were
a fantasy you know
and it was became an obsession i mean it
was like a beautiful mind i used to keep
a magic marker i got a magic marker i'd
dry erase marker in my bathroom
so that if i was in the shower and had
an idea as soon as i got on the show i'd
write it in the tiles and i'd stand
there brushing my teeth in the morning
or the evening and i'd read one of the
notes that i wrote on the thailand i
have another idea and if you walked into
my bathroom the tiles were filled with
ideas i love it i mean it was it was abs
and i mean it was really
insanity i mean it was fun though
but uh but i lost two relationships over
the course of that book yeah because i
was
not i was not myself i was stressed out
and i was short and you know it was and
as soon as the book was done i'm still
friends with with one of my exes who was
the one i was dating
the writing that book and she she
like she only knew me in that period and
she knows me now and she's like this is
better wow
it's not just nicer i'm just i'm i'm
less stressed yeah but would i have
changed it no yeah i i those sacrifices
that would have been nice for those
relationships to to to blast but but you
know the
the book
the message is bigger let me tell you a
story
so a friend of mine and i
we went for a run in central park
the road runners organization uh on the
weekends they host races
and it's very common at the end of the
race they'll have a sponsor who will
give away something apples or bagels or
something and on this particular day
when we got to the end of the run there
were some free bagels and they had
picnic tables set up and on one side was
a group of volunteers on the table were
boxes of bagels and on the other side
was a long line of runners waiting to
get their free bagel
so i said to my friend let's let's get a
bagel and he looked at me and said
ah the line's too long
and i said
free bagel
and he said i don't want to wait
in line
and i was like
free bagel
and he says nah let's it's too long
and that's when i realized that there's
two ways to see the world
some people see the thing that they want
and some people see the thing that
prevents them from getting the thing
that they want
i could only see the bagels
he could only see the line
and so
i walked up to the line
i
leaned in between two people
put my hand in the box and pulled out
two bagels
and no one got mad at me
because the rule is you can go after
whatever you want you just cannot deny
anyone else to go after whatever they
want now i had to sacrifice choice i
didn't get to choose which bagel i got i
got whatever i pulled out but i didn't
have to wait in line
so the point is is you don't have to
wait in line you don't have to do it the
way everybody else has done it you can
do it your way
you can break the rules you just can't
get in the way of somebody else getting
what they want
that's rule number one i talk to so many
smart fantastic ambitious idealistic
hard hard-working kids
and they're right out of college they're
in their entry-level jobs and i'll ask
them how's it going and they'll say
i think i'm going to quit
and i'm like why
they say to me
i'm not making an impact
i'm like you know you've been here eight
months right
they treat the sense of fulfillment or
even love like it's a scavenger hunt
like it's something you look for my
millennial friends they've gone through
so many jobs they're either getting
fired i mean it was mutual
or they're quitting
because they're not making an impact or
they're not finding the thing they're
looking for they're not feeling
fulfilled as if it's a scavenger hunt
love
a job you
find joy from
is not something you discover it's not
like i found love
here it is
i found a job i love that's not how it
works
both of those things require hard work
you are in love because you work very
hard every single day of your life to
stay in love
you find a job that brings you ultimate
joy because you work hard every single
day to serve those around you and you
maintain that joy it's not a discovery
but the problem is the sense of
impatience
it's as if an entire generation is
standing at the foot of a mountain they
know exactly what they want they can see
the summit what they can't say is the
mountain
this large
immovable object
that doesn't mean you have to do your
time that's not what i'm talking about
take a helicopter climb i don't care but
there's still a mountain
life career fulfillment relationships
are journeys
the problem is
this entire generation has an
institutionalized sense of impatience
and do they have the patience to go on
the journey to maintain love to feel
fulfilled or do they just quit and on to
the next dump and on to the next
ghost and on to the next in the
18th century
there was something that
spread across europe and eventually made
its way to america puerto fever
also known as the black death of child
bed
basically what was happening
is women were giving birth
and they would die within 48 hours after
giving birth
this black death of childbirth
was the ravage of europe and it got
worse and worse and worse over the
course of over a century
in some hospitals
it was as high as 70 percent of women
who gave birth who would die as a result
of giving birth
but this was the renaissance
this was the time of empirical data and
science and we had thrown away things
like tradition and mysticism these were
men of science these were doctors
and these doctors and men of science
wanted to study and try and find the
reason
for this black death of child bed and so
they got to work studying and they would
study the corpses
of the
of the women who had died and in the
morning they would conduct autopsies
and then in the afternoon they would go
and deliver babies and finish their
rounds
and it wasn't until somewhere in the
mid-1800s
that dr oliver wendell holmes father of
supreme court justice oliver wendell
holmes realized
that all of these doctors were
conducting autopsies in the morning
weren't washing their hands
before they delivered babies in the
afternoon
and he pointed it out and said guys
you're the problem
and they ignored him and called him
crazy
for 30 years
until finally somebody realized that if
they simply washed their hands
it would go away
and that's exactly what happened when
they started sterilizing their
instruments and washing their hands the
black death of childbed
disappeared
my point is
the lesson here is
sometimes you're the problem
we've seen this happen all too recently
with our new men of science and
empirical
studiers and
these men of
finance
who were smarter than the rest of us
until the thing collapsed
and they blamed everything else except
themselves
and my point is is take accountability
for your actions you can take all the
credit in the world for the things that
you do right as long as you also take
responsibility for the things you do
wrong it must be a balanced equation you
don't get it one way and not the other
you get to take credit
when you also take accountability and
how are people i see a lot of questions
here around dealing with a negative team
or dealing with a team where we feel
people may not have the right intentions
or the right motives how do people work
with that the viewers are asking yeah it
happens um and the answer is don't worry
about it like we can't obsess about the
ones that are doing something wrong we
obsess about the ones that are doing
something right instead of criticizing
the ones that are negative we want to
build up and complement the ones that
are positive because when that's the
reward structure which is finding and
identifying and rewarding good
then everybody wants to be rewarded and
recognized and so eventually the
behavior comes in as opposed to
criticizing wrong nobody wants to be
criticized and all it does is it makes
people back away and afraid so the point
is ignore the negativity and focus on
the positivity and start obsessing about
the people that are doing something
right i learned this lesson the hard way
um i wrote a blog and we had a
uh somebody write in with a very
aggressive sort of note to me and sort
of saying i'm a hypocrite and all of
this stuff and my team got together and
we discussed our response and somebody
wrote back and he rebecca very nicely
responds back and we thought okay how do
we react to this and i eventually got on
the phone with him and tried to talk
with him and he talked him off the shelf
and talked about the you know it was
okay and about six months later i wrote
another blog and he wrote another and we
got together and it occurred to us we
were spending all of this time with one
negative person and we were ignoring
all of the people who wrote in
compliments and were supporting our work
and so we literally made a decision that
day that when we got results like that
we wouldn't care and that if we were
going to invest any time of our people
it was going to be to say thank you to
the people who were helping us and
helping compliment us and helping
advance the message and so we don't i
personally don't respond to those at all
anymore ever but i
regularly call people up to say thank
you for helping advance the cause and it
feels nicer and there's time better
spent and we're not wasting time anyway
so yeah focus on the positive i
was boarding a flight i've told this
story i was boarding a flight and a
scene played out in front of me
where one of the passengers attempted to
board the plane before their group
number was called
and the gate agent
literally berated him sir step aside i
haven't called your group please step
aside and wait till i call your group
so i spoke up and said why do you have
to talk to us that way why can't you
talk to us like we're human beings
and she looked me in the eye and said if
i don't follow the rules i could get in
trouble or lose my job
all she revealed to me is that she
doesn't feel safe in her own company and
her leaders do not trust her to do the
job for which she's been trained to do
and guess who suffers us and the company
the reason we love flying southwest
airlines is because the company trusts
them to do the job they would they've
been trained to do and they use
discretion we don't trust people to
follow the rules we trust people to know
when to break them
and the problem is in a fear-based
society people fear for their own jobs
more than common sense
that was a perfectly
a perfect scenario of what happens when
somebody in the company is too afraid
to break the rule break the policy use
discretion find another way
you know
so
almost predictable that something will
happen and something will break at some
point
performing under pressure whether it's
me or anybody else is the same you know
i have the same pressures as anyone else
there's time there's performance there's
financial i mean there are you know
there's deadlines my pressures are not
unique um the situations may be
different or you know but but everybody
has the same kinds of pressures um but
what i found or what i find fascinating
is the interpretation of the stimuli if
let me let me explain
so i was watching the olympics this last
summer olympics and i was amazed at how
bad the questions were that the
reporters would ask all the athletes and
almost always they asked the same
question whether they were about to
compete or after they competed
were you nervous
right
and to a t
all the athletes went
no
right and what i realized is it's not
that they're not nervous it's their
interpretation of what's happening in
their bodies i mean what happens when
you're nervous right your heart rate
starts to go
you're you know you sort of get a little
tense you get a little sweaty right you
have expectation of what's coming and we
interpreted that as i'm nervous
now what's the interpretation of excited
your heart rate starts to go you become
you're anticipating what's coming right
you get a little sort of like tense it's
all the same thing it's the same stimuli
except these athletes these these
olympic quality athletes have learned to
interpret the stimuli that the rest of
us would say as nervous
as excited they all say the same thing
no i'm not nervous i'm excited
and so i've actually practiced it just
to tell myself when i start to get
nervous that this is excitement yeah you
know and so where when you i used to
speak in front of a large audience and
somebody would say how do you feel i
should say a little nervous
now when somebody says how do you feel
i'm like really excited actually and it
it came from just sort of telling myself
no no this is excitement
and it becomes a little bit automatic
later on um but it's kind of a
remarkable thing to deal with pressure
by interpreting what your body is
experiencing as excitement rather than
nerves
and it's really kind of effective it
makes you want to rush forward rather
than pull back and yet it's the same
experience every decision we make in our
lives as individuals or as organizations
is a piece of communication it's our way
of saying something about who we are and
what we believe
this is why authenticity matters
this is why you have to say and do the
things you actually believe because the
things you say and do are symbols
of who you are
and we look for those symbols so we can
find people who believe what we believe
our very survival depends on it so if
you're putting out false symbols you
will attract people to those symbols but
you won't be able to form trust with
them this is what tiger woods did to us
he lied
he lied he told us what he thought we
wanted to hear and it was great and we
were drawn to it and all of us who kind
of liked that idea of the sort of the
good guy were drawn to it until we found
out it was a lie
he could have been the bad boy of golf
he could have had all the same
endorsements and had a fantastic career
and still been hailed as one of the
great athletes of our day
but he didn't he chose to lie
good luck forming trust again tiger we
don't believe you
we don't trust you
the goal of putting something out there
if you say what you believe and you do
what you believe you will attract people
who believe what you believe
if you go to one of your friends and you
say to one of your friends
how would you like me to dress
so that you'll like me better
how would you want me to address you how
do you want me to speak
so that you'll like me more
right your friends are going to look at
you and be like
what are you talking about
come on come on come on what should i
wear so that you'll find me more
appealing and how would you like me to
speak to you so that you like me more
and your friends are going to tell you
just be yourself
that's why i like you i don't just be
yourself now think about what we do in
industry what do we do we do market
research and we go and we ask the
customers what kind of things the way we
what style should we speak to you how
should we decorate ourselves what kind
of things are you drawn to so that we
can do those things so you'll like us
more it's just as ridiculous
it's just as ridiculous organizations
should say and do the things they
actually believe and they will attract
people who believe what they believe or
they can choose to lie and at the
slightest hint that they might be lying
cynicism sets in and people start saying
i'm not sure i can trust these guys
because there's not a lot of consistency
in all the things they say and do which
means they can't have a very strong
belief set or they're lying to me
and we call them inauthentic the entire
process of asking other people who we
should be is inauthentic that's
hilarious to me
all these positioning studies we do are
inherent we're going to do a study to
find out from people so we can be more
authentic that's hilarious
say and do what you actually believe and
the symbols you put out there the things
you say and the things you do those red
hats
are ways that people can find you what
you have the ability to do
as designers is create those symbols
and allow people to use those things to
say something about who they are work
for companies work for clients work for
people who you believe what they believe
show up and feel a part of something
bigger than yourself
and your part is to put what they
believe into pictures and words and
symbols and graphics so that other
people can use those things to say
something about who they are
people put harley davidson logos on
their body to say something about who
they are corporate logo ain't no proctor
and gambles tattooed on anybody's arm
because harley means something they
stand for something people put that
tattoo on there not to tell you that
they own a motorcycle they put that
tattoo there to tell you something about
themselves
you ever see anybody with a with a mac
laptop put a sticker over that beautiful
shining apple ain't never going to
happen
then how will you know who i am
do you ever see anybody with a pc break
out the windex to clean out their
computer
mac people
have you ever seen a dirty mac
doesn't exist
does not exist why because it's who i am
these are symbols we use the companies
that are crystal clear in what they
believe
and they're disciplined in how they do
it they're consistent what they do and
everything they say and everything they
do serves as a symbol of the set of
values and beliefs we use those symbols
to say something about who we are
we surround ourselves with the people
and the products and the brands that say
something about who we are
and when we can find the people who
believe what we believe we're weirdly
drawn to them
because our very survival
depends on it we need it
and so the more you can give of yourself
the more you can give of what you
believe the more you can
discipline with discipline say
and do the things you actually believe
strange things start to happen what are
your thoughts and what's your approach
on finding and building upon passions
passion is not
an actionable word
it's correct you know that those who do
the things that they're passionate about
do better but it's not helpful advice
and so the question is where does
passion come from um
passion is a result passion is an energy
passion is the feeling you have when
you're engaged in something that
you love passion is the feeling you have
that
you would probably do this for free you
know and you can't believe somebody pays
you to do it you know um and i think we
mistake that passion is something we do
in our private lives but it shouldn't be
done you know in our careers for example
and i'm a firm believer that you are who
you are and anybody who says i'm
different at home than i am at work and
one of those two places you're lying and
the goal is to make everything you do in
home and at work something that you have
excitement to do so how do you find the
things that you're excited to do well
it's actually
easier than you think
what are the things that you love to do
what are the things that you would do
for free you know how can you recreate
that feeling
and and be paid for it so what are the
things that i do on the weekend right i
love um i'm very involved
in the art world i love to go to museums
and galleries but i love to go see dance
and performances because i want to see
how others are interpreting the world so
that inspires me new ideas new thoughts
new ways of looking at the world are
things that interest me privately and i
seek it out and pay money for it right
so does that mean i have to have a
career in the arts no it means i have to
have a career where new ideas are
explored where people are experimenting
and trying things out and i have to
explore new ideas and try things out and
i'm just as excited to go to work every
day as i am to
you know go do something on a saturday
night
and so the idea of finding your passion
is ironically simple because you should
be doing stuff that you enjoy
sometimes
what is the stuff that you enjoy and
then what is the stuff that you love who
are the people that you love and what
are those what they all have in common
here's an organization
with a vision a cause it was founded
with a cause it's an entrepreneurial
venture it's america is an experiment
it's an entrepreneurial venture where a
bunch of people got together and decided
we needed to start our own country
because there were certain obstacles
that were getting in the way of a vision
that we had of a better kind of country
but a kind of company right
and they stated it right at the
beginning all men are created equal
endowed with these unalienable rights
and much amongst which include life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness
and it's not a uh it's not just um a
competitive statement like to be the
best to be the most respected that's not
what it was and i'm amazed how many
companies start their visions or
missions with those that terribly
egocentric language it was an ideal
and the amazing thing is is we've been
good at it and bad at it in our history
but
it's endured for 240 plus years
because we fundamentally believe that we
are at our best when we're pursuing that
but it is an ideal we will never
actually achieve all people are equal
but we will die trying and that's the
point
and it's the same for a company which is
true vision inside a company is
something that has nothing to do with
your product it is an ideal
to which you will attempt to build and
advance that ideal through your company
with your product you'll never achieve
the ideal but you'll die trying and this
is what gives our work meaning this is
what it gives our lives purpose right
the difference between vision and a goal
is the finish line a goal is 26.2 miles
you can simply count the metrics and
know when you've completed your goal
a vision is having a crystal clear sense
of what the finish line looks like but
no idea of how far away it is wow and
it's and the reality is you will spend
your entire life never actually crossing
the finish line but the joy that every
marathon you complete you feel like
you're getting closer every milestone
that you accomplish makes you feel like
you're getting closer and closer to the
ideal and this is what gives our life
and our work meaning success is an
elusive thing right um
what is it
and i think it's very interesting that
if most people can't define success well
it means you made x amount of dollars or
but if you make x amount of dollars but
you spend more are you successful or
well it means you come home happy every
day okay how do you know when you're
happy you know uh
so
i think success is a funny thing which
is we all seem to pursue it but we don't
know how to measure it or actually how
to define it
so how do you pursue something that you
can't measure fascinating
um so
when people say to me how do you measure
success the question we all have to ask
ourselves am i successful
i don't know i mean i had a good year
last year uh
and what does that mean does that mean i
made a lot of money does that mean i was
really happy oh i'll let you decide
right right um maybe neither maybe both
um
i had a good year last year but am i
successful and the answer is no i don't
feel i am because i'm trying to build a
world that doesn't exist yet i'm trying
to build a world in which 90 of people
go home at the end of the day feeling
fulfilled by the work that they do so i
definitely took a step a big step
forward towards that goal but i'm still
so far away so somebody said to me then
how do you know if you're successful and
the answer is
if it can go by itself and so what is
more interesting to me as a measurement
of success is not the the the markers
per se it's not the the financial goal
or the
the size of the house that you want to
buy those are nice things go for it
those are but those are not measurements
of success those are just nice things to
collect along the way
um
for me it's momentum i want to measure
momentum which is you know when when
something is moving and you start to see
it lose momentum you're like oh
give it a push because if you don't give
it a push it's going to stop and an
object in stasis is much harder to get
going it requires a lot more energy to
get something started than it does to
keep it going right and so if you don't
let it stop and you can keep it going
it's this you know it still might slow
down there but you can get it going
again much easier and for me the
opportunity is to get the ball rolling
faster and faster and faster and faster
and faster and bigger and bigger and
bigger it's like a snowball and my
responsibility is because it's not
rolling downhill yet it's not on
automatic yet i need to still keep it
going to find that critical mass where
it can go
and at the point it can go by itself
without me then i will find something
else to do and that may not happen in my
lifetime i think we must all stop
measuring promotions salaries and these
things but rather measure the momentum
of your career does my career have
momentum can i see it moving in the
right direction can i see it gathering
moss you know uh can i see that it's
easy becoming easier for me to keep the
momentum it's becoming easier for me to
grow the size of this thing it's it's
requiring less effort that's the thing
we need to measure that's the thing that
we need to be cognizant of which is the
momentum of our careers not just the the
markers that we think define our success
i did a little experiment with um
um
with a homeless person
not like on them it's not like
electrodes
with them voluntarily um helped me
um
because the whole idea of giving right
you have
you've all walked down the street and
you've all seen someone begging and you
either have or haven't
thrown a few pennies in their cup
when you do you feel good
you bought that feeling
that is a legitimate commercial
transaction you know commercial
transactions are defined as the exchange
of consideration there was an exchange
of consideration here you gave money
you got the feeling of goodwill you paid
for that feeling if you didn't give
money you either feel nothing or you
feel bad
you can't feel good by not giving
all right you paid for that feeling so
now the question is how is that person
encouraging us to give the joke is they
act like every corporation in the world
they talk about themselves
me me me me me me me right like they sit
there with their little outdoor
advertising
little sign
right
and it says i'm homeless i'm hungry i
got 12 kids i'm a veteran god bless they
got it all in there trying to appeal to
somebody the religious vote the veteran
vote you know the child sympathizer
surround yourself with lots of pets go
for that one too
right
all in an attempt to get something from
someone
takers
not givers right all about me well what
do corporations do we've added more ram
we've added more rom we've added more
speed this one's number one we're the
biggest we're the best we've been around
since 1969 we're better than them we're
faster than them we're more efficient
than that one me me me me me me me me
and so even if we buy their product
guess what yeah we don't really feel
much
so i did this little experiment i found
um
a nice homeless lady on the streets of
new york who's willing to help out and i
learned that with her sign which was
pretty typical i'm homeless i'm hungry
she makes between 20 and 30 dollars a
day
uh for you know for a day's worth of
work eight to ten hours of sitting there
selling goodwill
eight to ten hours she'll make twenty to
thirty dollars thirty dollars is
considered a good day
i changed her sign
and the new sign
made her forty dollars in two hours
and then she left
[Music]
it's one of the reasons she's homeless
is because she's decided that she only
needs 20 to 30 dollars a day to live if
she stayed she would have made 150
the point is she made 40 bucks in two
hours what did the signs say
the sign said if you only give once a
month please think of me next time
it has nothing to do with the taker it
has everything to do with the giver
and what are the objections people give
when they don't
give
i can't give to everyone
how do i know that they really need it
and so i address both those concerns i
know you can't give to everyone so if
you only give once a month my cause is
legitimate i will still be here when
you're ready to give
40 bucks two hours make it about them
not about you
the fact of the matter is one hundred
percent of customers
are people
and one hundred percent of clients
are people and one hundred percent of
employees are people i don't care how
good your product is i don't care how
good your marketing is i don't care how
good your design is if you don't
understand people you don't understand
business
we are social animals we are human
beings and our survival depends on our
ability to form trusting relationships
do you ever watch um
deadliest catch
on the discovery channel
i was looking through channels one night
and deadliest catch came on and on this
episode
just random
they were in a huge storm now for those
of you who don't know deadliest catch
uh they take these crab fishing boats
out in the bering sea which is like
terrible
and they put cameras on them and we
watch
right
the reason that's i guess significant is
because these crab fishermen have i
think one of the top five deadliest jobs
in the world you know i don't know what
the exact number is but dozens of
fishermen die every year
doing doing this we apparently find that
entertaining
which it actually is
so they have cameras only on five or six
of the ships even though there are many
many many ships that go out fishing
every season and they don't really come
into proximity with each other because
you know the ocean's huge and they
usually sabotage each other and give
each other false information because
they're all competitors they're all
looking to get the crabs and you know
make sure that they find them somebody
else doesn't and yeah it's business
right it's just business it's okay we
all do the same thing in our own
companies
and in this one episode this big huge
storm was so violent that they had to
bring all the pots which are the big
cages that they catch the crabs and they
had to bring all the pots back on the
boat
and wait out the storm and just by dumb
luck one of the
boats that had cameras on it
was in proximity of a boat that didn't
have cameras on it and so they filmed
they had secured all their pots on the
deck and so they started filming the
other boat
and they filmed a guy climbing on the
outside of the cage securing
the pots
and all of a sudden a huge wave
hits the side of the boat
and the guy's not there
anymore and the people on the boat with
the cameras start screaming man
overboard man overboard man overboard
and they turn their boat
towards
where they think he might be
he's a stranger they don't know him they
don't know the the crew members of the
other boat and yet they react
and they turn towards him
and they find him in the drink
and
for those of you who don't understand
how dangerous this is if the water is so
cold that if you're in the water for i
think that it's a minute or a minute 30.
hypothermia will set and then you die
and
they come upon him
and he's screaming don't let me die
don't let me die
and they pull him on board
not out of the woods yet they strip off
his clothes because it's wet and cold
and they wrap blankets around him to
prevent hyperthermia from setting in
and he survives
and it's overwhelming
and
the captain comes down
and this is all i mean you can go watch
it on tv the camera comes the captain
comes down and he hugs this stranger
this young man his competitor he hugs
this guy as if he's his own
son i
i lost it
everybody is crying
and you realize what happened here was a
human interaction
and the reason they risked their own
lives to help this other person even
though they spend every other day trying
to get ahead and sabotage is because at
the end of the day they're all crab
fishermen and they know something about
each other and they know something about
the risk that they all take
to do this
and when push comes to shove
they will put themselves out there to
help each other for no other reason
than they get it
they're one of the same
i will promise you
that every single member of that crew
that day
went home with a feeling of fulfillment
i promise you that every single person
on that crew that day
felt more good in their hearts and in
their jobs than the richest days that
they've ever pulled in
my question is is what are you doing to
help the person next to you
don't you want to wake up
and go to work for the only reason that
you can do something good for someone
else
wouldn't you want them to do that for
you biggest risk you've ever taken um
i completely changed the course of my
life and career when i discovered this
thing called the why i abandoned what i
was doing and said i want to do that and
people thought i was crazy they thought
i went out of business but i was so i
believed in it so much i i threw caution
into the wind
i think why has been the key my whole
life to worldwide so it's a little kid
question that we grow out of for some
reason the game
of business
is
an infinite game
right it obeys all the rules
there are known and unknown players you
don't know all the competitors
necessarily in one industry to another
the rules are changeable we haven't all
agreed what the rules are
and there is no winning the game of
business right the game just perpetuates
in fact the game of business has existed
longer than every single company on the
planet today and it will outlast every
single commodore company on the planet
today if you look at the dow index of 30
something odd companies that make up the
dow index something like 70 or 80
percent of those companies are 35 years
or younger
right
so it gets me thinking if you listen
to the language that companies use
they don't know what game they're in
they talk about being number one
talk about beating their competition
based on what agreed upon criteria based
on what agreed upon time frame is it
market share is it profits is it
revenues
square footage number of employees over
what one month five months six months a
year five years ten years the life of
the company i haven't agreed to those
rules
and so companies can arbitrarily declare
themselves number one in anything they
want if they set the standards and the
time frames
and the only reason we do these things
on annualized bases we tend to we tend
to compare ourselves to other
organizations annually
is only because we pay taxes annually if
we pay taxes every 18 months that would
be sort of the standard but again we
still haven't agreed
what the metrics are to be number one
that means
the companies that are playing the
infinite game
are playing against most of the others
who are playing the finite game means
those finite companies find themselves
in quagmire
almost every single bankruptcy not
almost every every single bankruptcy is
a company that's run out of the will or
the resources to play they drop out of
the game the game will persist another
company will fill their space it's not
like it's not like the business stops or
the industry ends
and uh
the companies that are playing the
infinite game will frustrate those
finite players which i absolutely adore
so i spoke at an education summit for
microsoft
i also spoke at an education summit for
apple
now i would say about 70 to 80 percent
of the executives at microsoft spent
about seventy to eighty percent of their
power points
talking about how to beat apple
at the apple summit a hundred percent of
the executives spent a hundred percent
of their presentations talking about how
to help teachers teach and how to help
students learn
one was obsessed with their journey with
their vision with their cause the other
one was obsessed with their competition
guess who's stuck in quagmire guess
who's frustrated
by their competition so i'll tell you
another story
it's a personal story it's not one that
i share very often
and it profoundly changed
the course of my life
in august of 2011
i had the opportunity to visit
afghanistan with the united states air
force
i had done some work with the mobility
forces these the people that fly the
tankers and the cargo planes and air
force one
all the big planes
and the general said to me simon you've
gotten to know us quite well
it would mean a lot to me
if you would go
to either iraq or afghanistan to see our
men and women perform their mission
would you be willing to go
so i said yes
they picked afghanistan
now i didn't tell my parents where i was
going because i didn't want them to
worry
i told them i was going away with the
air force true
i told them i was going to be out of
touch for a while because i was going to
be on a lot of planes
true
i told them i was going to germany
true
i just didn't tell them from germany i
was going to afghanistan
and i had no responsibility i was simply
going as an observer
i had two officers who were assigned to
be my escorts and we met basically for
the first time
at penn station in philadelphia where we
drove to dover air force base where we
would leave for germany we took a big c5
cargo plane
in germany we changed planes and we got
on a kc-135 tanker
built in 1956.
i was on a plane built in 1956
where we flew to bagram
we landed in the middle of the night we
touched down
and the big door in the side of the
plane had opened but we hadn't gotten
off the plane yet we'd been on the we'd
been on the ground for maybe 10 minutes
and the base came under rocket attack
three rockets hit 100 yards off our nose
this is how my trip began
now if you've ever been in a war zone
for those of you in the room who've ever
been in a war zone you have you know
this you have all the feelings you're
supposed to have you just don't have
them at the right times
weirdly i was incredibly relaxed and
maybe that's because the people i was
with were incredibly relaxed and i felt
safe
we revenge the panic came later
we're eventually given the all clear and
we went to our housing
now the purpose of being in afghanistan
we were going to be in the country for
up to 30 hours and the goal was to
witness an airdrop mission
they're not regularly scheduled so we
had to find out if there was one as soon
as we got there and it turns out there
was one first thing in the morning
so we got about two and a half hours
three hours of sleep
and we went and got on this air drop
mission which was incredible we sat in
the back of a c-17 we flew about an hour
and a half two hours out to the middle
of nowhere afghanistan the plane dropped
down to about 2000 feet the back door
opened and we sat there and watched as
cargo flew out the back so we could
resupply an army forward operating base
it was an amazing amazing experience
we then flew back to bagram and the goal
was to come back home there's no
regularly scheduled flight so we have to
sort of find out what flights we can get
on and it's always up to the discretion
of the pilots we found a flight that was
leaving
shortly after we got back and so we
asked the pilots and they said
absolutely we can join their flight and
we waited and waited and waited and
waited and waited and waited and
eventually we got on the plane we were
all strapped in literally five minutes
from leaving and the pilot walked up to
us and said i'm sorry we need to bump
you guys we need to make more room for
stretchers it was carrying wounded
warriors out of out of theater and they
needed our space
if there's ever a good reason to get
bumped off a plane this was it so we got
off the plane and we went to look for
another flight
and that's when we found out
there were no other flights until
tuesday and this was only saturday
i was going to get stuck in afghanistan
for at least four days maybe longer
because we don't know what we're going
to get on on tuesday and i have no way
of telling my parents
they're not going to hear from me on the
date that i told them that i would get
home
immediately every fiber of my being sank
and i remember becoming completely
panicked
and completely preoccupied with one
thing
my happiness my safety and my comfort
and i didn't care who had to go out of
their way to get me what i wanted
i remember there was a public affairs
officer who said i can get you to
kyrgyzstan but you don't have the right
visa and i looked at him and i said you
get me on that plane i don't talk to
people like that and i could see myself
becoming this person that i hated
some of us in the room have worked for
somebody in our careers who
wants the next promotion and they don't
care that they have to tie our turn our
lives upside down so they can get what
they want i was becoming that person
we went back to our housing
and i lay down on the bed and closed my
eyes
my mind was racing i was convinced that
there would be another rocket attack on
the base i was convinced that i was
going to get hit i was convinced that my
parents were going to find out that i
was in afghanistan when an arm an air
force officer knocks on the door i was
convinced paranoia fear everything that
you can imagine swept over me
one of the officers that i was traveling
with said i'm gonna see if i can get us
on another flight and he left the room
the other officer thinking i was asleep
just because my eyes were closed said
well i'm gonna go to the gym then and he
walked out and turned off the lights for
me
i couldn't sleep my mind was racing all
i wanted to do was get out of there i
regretted saying yes i regretted being
there i didn't want to be there
i'm in the purpose business i write and
talk about this sense of why and sense
of purpose in our lives
so i started to remind myself simon you
need a purpose you don't have a purpose
you need a purpose so i started
inventing one
you're here to tell their story
it worked for like a few minutes and i
would slide back into my fear and panic
again
and i realized what was happening to me
is i was living the equivalent of an
unfulfilled life compressed into 24
hours
i had an amazing day i got to see
something that most people will never
get to see in their entire lives except
i didn't want to wake up and do it again
the next day
and i think many of us do the same thing
we can we confuse moments of happiness
with joy and fulfillment
we confuse winning a piece of business
getting a promotion getting an award
getting recognition doing well on a test
with actual deep
fulfillment those experiences are
wonderful but happiness is fleeting
there's not a single person in this room
absolutely zero who's walking around
with an amazing sense of accomplishment
for that test that you aced a year
ago that feeling
is gone
fulfillment is something entirely
different
it's something you carry with you on a
daily basis whether you're enjoying the
day or not
it's like loving your family you may not
like your family every day but you love
your family every day
one is fleeting the other is lasting
and this is what was happening to me i
realized that i had this amazing day and
i was confusing
happiness and fulfillment
and so i gave up i lay in that bed
paranoid scared and depressed and i
literally
gave up
i decided that if i was gonna get stuck
here
i might as well make myself useful
and so i decided i was going to
volunteer i would speak anywhere they
wanted me to speak
i would carry boxes and sweep floors all
i wanted to do was serve some of those
amazing people that i'd met on this trip
i wanted to serve those who served
others
and instantly this incredible calm came
over me
i was even
excited
this is what fulfillment means
it's not the fleeting joys that we may
experience it's not the accomplishments
that we achieve
it's the opportunity to serve those who
serve others
and upon making this realization i had
nothing but joy and calm and excitement
and peace
it was like a movie the timing was
uncanny upon making this amazing
realization the door flung open
and it was major throch morton he said i
got us on a flight there's been a flight
that's been redirected but we have to go
now we have to go now if we don't leave
now they're going to leave without us
where's matt i said he's at the gym
so we ran to the gym we got him off the
treadmill we ran back no time to shower
he put his uniform back on we grabbed
all our stuff and we ran out to the
flight line
when we got out to the flight line we
could see the plane we were gonna go we
were gonna take home
see big c-17 it was sitting right out
there on the tarmac and as soon as we
got there a security cordon came down
and they wouldn't let us out to the
plane
because somewhere else on base
they were having a fallen soldier
ceremony
and out of respect when they have the
fallen soldiers ceremony everything
stops
and so so we we sat on the curb and
waited
and i told the guys what i had gone
through
in the bed just moments ago
and i cried like a baby
and this is one of the things a lot of
people don't realize about the military
crying is just fine
those guys kept me safe not just
physically they made me feel safe
and i felt totally comfortable telling
them what i was going through and how i
felt
eventually this security cordon came up
and they let us out to the plane we
would be the only three passengers
aboard this plane other than the crew
what i didn't tell you
is the reason the flight was redirected
is because we would be carrying home the
fallen soldier for whom they just had
the ceremony
the army
brought the flag draped casket on board
all the air force crew stood in the line
at perfect attention i'm a civilian i
put my hand on my heart i felt kind of
stupid so i stood at attention with the
air force
crew as the army laid the casket in the
middle of the aircraft they hold it a
very slow eight-count salute
they marched off the plane
and we watched them hugging and crying
as they walked away
the crew got to work strapping this
precious cargo down
we then had a nine and a half hour
overnight flight back to germany
where i slept right next to this casket
on every other plane i went on we talked
we joked barely a word was spoken in
nearly 10 hours on every other flight i
visited the cockpit and hung out with
the crew i didn't visit the cockpit once
and i'll tell you it was one of the
greatest honors of my life
having just gone through this incredibly
strange experience on the ground
i had the honor of bringing home
somebody who understands service much
deeper than i will ever understand it
serve those who serve others
and you will live a life of joy
and fulfillment so i was
living in london and attending law
school i was becoming disillusioned with
the law i happened to be dating a girl
who was in advertising she said you
might like advertising and boom i have a
career in marketing like i fell into it
so many of us fall into our careers and
full entire jobs and even if we do
pursue something we want to do sometimes
it takes diversions right this is this
is what i mean by living our lives by
accident which is we largely leave the
direction of our careers and sometimes
even our own happiness to others our
bosses you know all of that thing
so what it means to live your life on
purpose means you understand the
direction you're heading but you remain
agnostic as to the root most people try
very very hard to plan the route in
other words what's your plan people say
well first i'm going to work here for
three years then i'm going to quit and
i'm going to do this and then for four
years and i got the root plan and the
question is where are you going right
and that to me is what it means to have
purpose it means to have destination
right it's like waking up in the morning
and saying i'm going on holiday somebody
says where are you going i said i'm
going on vacation i told you you're like
where are you going
vacation
right um and so how are you going to get
there like well i'm taking route 95 so
you've got the route planned but you
have no destination and you see this in
companies all the time you know why does
your company exist growth
great why are you growing why do you
need to grow what does growth mean
because we're a company we have to grow
and so they figure out all of these
paths for growth but they don't know
where they're going i would rather
someone wake up in the morning and say
california i'm trying to get to
california and i don't care what route i
take i'm going to start down route 95
and if i find a better route i'm going
to take it if there's traffic on route
95 i'm going to take a side road so this
is what happened in my career people
kept telling me that i was unfocused
because i kept taking side roads i
wasn't unfocused i was going around
obstacles
so that's what it means to live a life
of purpose it means i live every single
day of my life trying to get to an end
point in my case to create a world in
which the vast majority of people wake
up every single morning inspired to go
to work feel safe when they're there and
return home at the end of the day
fulfilled by the work that they do that
is the destination i'm trying to
reach i don't know how i'm going to get
there but i'm going to try every path i
can to get there highly highly focused
that's what it means to live a life on
purpose we're often given this advice
like do what you love yeah like what am
i supposed to do with it yes like find
your passion like thank you like great
like i don't know what to do tomorrow
for me
passion is the result of something right
so if you work hard for something you
don't believe in that's called stress
and if you work for so hard for
something you do believe in that's
called passion so it's finding the
belief it's finding the cause it's
finding the purpose and the passion then
shows up so it's not about doing
something with passion and then finding
the cause it's finding the cause
starting with why and then the passion
is what is what results number two it's
embarrassing this has to be on the list
courageous leadership
courageous leaders are the ones who are
willing to sacrifice the short term in
order to advance the long term
courageous leaders are the ones who are
willing to say no to the money because
it's coming from a dirty source
and rather say yes even though they know
they'll have to tighten the belt in the
short term because it's the right thing
to do
having a just cause if we don't actually
follow the just cause if we don't
actually make decisions through the lens
of the just cause it's just marketing
it's just marketing i'll give you my
favorite example right the ioc the
international olympic committee they
have a mission statement what they
believe is their just cause which is to
uh
advance the world make the world a
better place through sport
but for the fact that they're all
corrupt
it's a great idea
my point is is you actually have to have
leadership that
desperately profoundly believes in the
cause and will make decisions to advance
that cause they would sooner sacrifice
their own personal interests to take
care of their people they would never
sacrifice their people to protect their
own interests
it's called leadership
it's called leadership we confuse rank
and leadership
rank has nothing to do with leadership
i know many people who sit at the
highest levels of organizations who are
not leaders they have authority
and we do as they tell us because they
have authority over us but we would not
follow them
and yet i know many people who sit at
lower ranks who have no authority and
yet they have made a choice the choice
to look after the person to the left of
them and the choice to look after the
person to the right of them and we would
trust them and follow them anywhere
leadership is the acceptance of the
awesome responsibility
to create an environment in which people
can work at their natural best i went to
see a play with a friend of mine who is
an actor
and the play was awful
i mean
a train wreck
the script was awful the directing was
awful i mean it's a it was an absolute
train wreck the question goes now
the question you asked was about
collaboration right should any of those
actors have taken the part now
of course
if you're going to take apart because
you need an extra cash a little extra
cash or you want to get a little extra
practice
then you have to do so i think knowing
i'm doing this for the money or i'm
doing this just to keep keep my
my skills sharp but i'm under no
illusion
that this is something that i connect
with but i'm going to do the best that i
can and then don't
lie to yourself you know the other
problem is don't do that too often
because that'll just destroy any passion
that you have for your medium right and
i think
and we've talked about this which is
which is
any artist any person but especially
artists have to know their why you have
to know why you're showing up in the
first place
and you have to be able to talk about it
because if you talk about it things
happen people go
i like you right now you may not get the
part
but you're more likely to find people
who want to work with you even if you're
not the most talented one who auditioned
this is my career by the way right
when i learned to talk about what i
believed
i didn't talk about the things i've done
i didn't talk about the parts i've had
or the shows i've been in or who trained
me
or the schools i went to resume resume
resume
i started i learned to talk about what i
believed and some people thought it was
cheesy
they didn't call me back
good
and some people went
that's great and i was not the most
talented not the most experienced
not the best at my field but because
they stood for or believed in what i
stood for
they wanted to work with me
they would rather work with someone who
understood them who got them
more than somebody who would just take
orders and do exactly what they wanted
regardless of facility there's a paradox
being a human being um unfortunately at
all times every moment of every day we
are both individuals and members of
groups right we are both responsible for
ourselves and our own happiness and our
own joy but at the same time we're
members of families we're members of
churches we're members of teams we're
members of companies like we're members
of multiple groups every single day at
every moment and this produces some
complications we have to make decisions
so do we put ourselves first or do we
put the group first and there's a debate
some people say oh you have to take care
of yourself before you can take care of
the group and some say no no you take
care of the group and that's what helps
they will take care of you and the
answer is yes it's not one or the other
it's actually both simultaneously
it is a challenge but at the end of the
day there's no getting around it as
social animals our success our happiness
our joy our ability to get anything done
requires help
and
those who embrace the fact that they
cannot do everything alone that they
need the support and love and it doesn't
mean somebody who's physically helping
you live something sometimes it might be
someone who just believes in you
these things are essential and there's
just no getting around it companies
obsess about their competitors which is
fine tactically which is fine for short
term but long term
most companies aren't brought down by
the competition they know about they're
brought down by the competition they
don't know about some new emerging
technology you know do you think the
music business was paying attention to
the computer business at all of course
not they were paying attention to other
music companies
um you know
myspace wasn't
focused on friends to uh facebook they
didn't even know facebook existed but
it's facebook that brought them down or
significantly hurt their business
right in other words if you don't even
know who your competitors are what's the
point of fixating and making all of your
business decisions based on competitors
all we're doing is reacting reacting
reacting this is why purpose matters it
gives us a north star yes we have to
concern ourselves with our competition
from a tactical and short-term point of
view but to make long-term strategic
decisions based on a competitive set
that we don't even know that's complete
based on technology that we don't even
know it's it's completely fully baked is
madness it's absolutely madness right so
you want to fixate on the on the the on
the path what do leaders need to do to
understand the trends in their industry
better because it's very easy to say
this is where this business or this is
where this competition this uh this
market is going it's actually that's
what everyone else is doing so how can
you get ahead of a trend in the way that
steve jobs was able to look at where the
puck is going so trend data is very
dangerous because all it does is report
a trend it doesn't report if it's
positive or negative and everyone else
has got it and everybody else has got it
so for example you know kids these days
are all using
apps to do everything we should make
more apps
but nobody says it's healthy
right in the 1980s you needed to do
cocaine to get through the business day
you know does that that's a trend that's
a trend it's not really true cocaine
usage was up in the 1980s
in businesses it was if you worked in
investment bank yeah yeah yeah no i was
i i was i was definitely not doing that
so the point is the point is it the
point is it's a trend yeah that doesn't
mean we should invest in it right so
trend data is i think the way people
rush towards a trend because they think
that's where the market is going is very
dangerous because it's incredibly
unstable information but you have to as
a leader anticipate where your market is
going and make three or five year plans
and the way you do it is with vision
right so
for some reason somebody keeps telling
me that i unders my publisher said this
to me that i'm good at understanding the
zeitgeist
uh
and he's wrong i have no clue
about what people are thinking
all i know is where i want to go that's
it
as i said before i have a vision of a
world in which the vast majority of
people wake up every single morning
inspired to go to work feel safe when
they're there and return home fulfilled
at the end of the day so i can make
certain guesses and predictions about
things i have to do to get there i've
become very very interested in the idea
of
playing in games that have no finish
lines
right
some games have finish lines
right baseball football right
um getting a part is the finish line you
audition
there's a beginning middle and end
there's rehearsal and practice
there's uh uh
uh showing up for the audition and you
either win or you lose and then it's
over
it's over right that is finite
but one's career
is infinite
there's there's no end it's like our
lives are fine but life is infinite
people come and people go but life
continues right here
actors come and actors go but theater
continues it's infinite you don't win
theater
you win a part
but what happens once you get the part
the the finite game is over
now you enter the infinite game you have
to be able to convert right and the
reason this is important and i've seen
this unfortunately so many times from a
young age all you wanted to do was get
to broadway
and then you get to broadway
and then what you've devoted your entire
life to one finite goal and when you get
there the immediate response is
depression
because i i spent 15 years of my life
for this one thing
and i got it
and now i don't know what to do next
like what a
get to broadway again
it doesn't have the same
ambition
it doesn't have the same passion
you know you've devoted you're from you
know you're from fargo north dakota and
that's all you wanted to do is get out
of fargo and make it to broadway and you
made it
right it doesn't have the same kind of
passion and this is because these are
finite goals
there's a lot of studies that have been
done
with
athletes who have finite goals
to become the greatest ex in the world
right so andre agassi was one of these
one of these athletes he wanted to
become the greatest tennis player that
ever lived guess what
everyone in his life he would he would
view them through how do you help me get
to that
everything was how does this help me get
to that everything was a transaction to
how do you help me move to there and
then you know what happens he achieved
it he became the greatest tennis player
in the world and you know what happened
immediately after
depression
michael phelps
set out to become the most meddled
olympian in history do you know what
he achieved it you know what happened
immediately after
depression
they spend their whole life working for
one goal though most will never get it
the few that do
don't know what to do next because their
goals were finite
their goals were finite
right and so
there are finite components to your
career
but your career should be infinite
so yes of course you have to win the
finite game you have to get the part but
immediately when you get the part now
you convert to infinite in military
we're willing to sacrifice ourselves for
the gain of others right but in business
we're willing to sacrifice others for
our own gain yes how do you build that
military mindset in companies like here
or other companies
leadership i mean it's it's leadership
creates an environment
and it's i mean this is what i learned
the the the whole concept of leaders eat
last and those lessons that i learned
from spending time with folks in uniform
it was born out of my own experience
where i i was going through a point in
my career as my career was growing all
of a sudden you have new friends that i
didn't have before
and and that's wonderful and then i
learned the hard way that they weren't
my friends they were playing me they
wanted access or a deal or something
right and i and i i learned it the hard
way and so i retreated i was like i
wanted to be friends with nobody else
but the people i knew way back when
which is also not a good way to live
and yet simultaneously i'm spending time
with tons of folks in the military who
you know in business we have colleagues
and co-workers in the military of
brothers and sisters and that's a
different kind of relationship and as
you know i have hugged more people in
uniform than i've ever hugged in suits
i've cried with more people in uniform
than i've ever cried with in suits i've
stood in the audience and listened to
officers give talks and i've sat in the
audience and cried i've never cried with
any ceo
gave a speech ever right
so there's a different nature of
relationship and my original conclusion
was they're better people
that the reason you get a
disproportionate amount of these kinds
of behaviors is because they're better
people and better people are drawn to a
life of service in the military which is
why we find a disproportionately high
number of them there and the more i
started to learn the more i realized i
was completely wrong
it's the environment
it's the environment and when the leader
creates an environment in which people
feel that someone has my back they will
do extraordinary things and what i
learned is that courage is not this deep
down internal fortitude
right it comes externally it's like a
trapeze artist would never try a brand
new death defying act unless they had a
net
the courage didn't come from
the trapezoid the courage came from the
net and it's the same
in
the military which is especially when
you're in life and death situations when
you're when you're when you're in
theater
people who you don't like you still rely
on to save your life and the reason it
works is because you don't have to look
behind your shoulder
and that mentality and you know better
than anybody which is
when you when you are deployed into
dangerous
places
nobody sort of loves deployment but
people have warm feelings towards
deployment which is really strange and
suicides rarely happen in in combat
situations they usually happen back home
and it's the intensity of the
relationships that create that warmth
and the sort of weird enjoyment of
really bad uncomfortable and dangerous
circumstances it's because this we're
human beings and human beings as social
animals
feel our safest
when we trust each other and good
leaders are capable of producing that so
great businesses look very much like
well-run military organizations and you
know there's poorly run military
organizations as well but great
businesses look exactly the same where
the leaders
give the glory they distribute authority
they push it down the ranks let people
make decisions if they screw up there's
no risk of getting fired if the company
misses its arbitrary projections on its
arbitrary date we do not use the people
to balance the books
we figure out other ways or we even
invite the people to help solve the
problems these are the things that
produce that circle of safety that
produces the exact same outcome where
people will love each other cry for each
other sacrifice for each other you see
it in business plenty
but it always boils down
to leadership
so with steve jobs playing the finite
game because he was crushing the
competition or was he playing the
infinite game because he just did his
own thing
so
jobs had a very clear vision
and it was to give the individual the
power to stand up to big brother he was
at his heart
a rebel he grew up in
northern california
during the vietnam war
which is the where the beginning of the
anti-establishment revolution sort of
started yeah and that was his childhood
um and so he really he really stood for
the individual standing up to
to to the man and he had a big spiritual
side he was a buddhist yeah
and if you look at the decisions he made
he made decisions like this he ran
decisions through his vision before he
got to the interests right
so there's a very famous story
of when he went to xerox park do you
know this one so jobs
they just come off the success of the
apple one and the apple ii it's already
a big company he's already well known
it's a it's he's already the darling of
business
um and uh their next big push is going
to be into a technology they called the
lisa that was their next computer
that they were going to launch and just
as executives do they visit each other's
companies and jobs and a few of his
colleagues went to visit xerox park
and xerox showed them a new technology
that they had invented called the
graphic user interface
right
now
remember jobs believed in the individual
standing up to big brother so the reason
they made their computers beautiful was
not arbitrary it's because if you had
them if they were pretty looking you'd
put them in the living room if they're
ugly you put them in the basement
and you're more likely to use something
that's in the living room than if it's
in the basement right
um the reason you make them simple is
because more people can then use them
and so when he saw this thing called the
graphic user interface he thought this
is a better technology
it's a leapfrog to make it easier for
more individuals to access the power of
the personal computer
than what we have in the lisa so that's
an infinite game because he's thinking
about what's right for the long term
rather than what his competition and as
they left dr park job says we have to
invest in this
and his colleagues said we're you're
crazy we've
invested millions of dollars
millions of man hours already in the
lisa if we do this
if we invest in this we're going to blow
up our own company to which jobs replied
better we should blow it up than someone
else
that decision became the mac the
macintosh that decision was the
macintosh
of which remember windows
is an interface designed to copy the
macintosh in other words he completely
changed the way computers work to the
point where now any individual
can easily use
a computer and he always made decisions
that way
he made decisions always empowering the
individual so he was asked
a question about the
movie industry cinemas and the decline
of cinemas
and he replied that the cinemas were
making the same mistake the movie
industry was making the same mistake
that the music industry made which is
the music industry falsely believed that
their customer was tower records and
virgin mega store
and not the person who actually spent
money on buying the album
he says you've confused your customer
with you with your distribution channel
if you want some amazing motivation from
robin sharma check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there
so i think we all want i think what's
happened on the planet right now is
there's been a great seduction and a
great brainwashing when we are kids we
want we want to be astronauts we want to
be billionaires